[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
הרך. טוב שלום לכולם.
אנחנו נמשיך את הדיון שלנו היום בסיכון Small, כלומר במקרים שבהם אנחנו רוצים לתת סדרה של פרטי קציעות שיש ביניהם תלות,
כן, וננסה להבין קצת מה הצורה שאנחנו ניגשים לבעיה.
הבעיה העיקרית שתלווה אותנו בהקשר הזה כן.
המשימה העיקרית זה משימת תיוג חלקי.
דיבר שדיברנו עליה קצת בסוף השיעור שעבר.
כלומר, בהינתן משפט שהיינו רוצים לגבי כל אחת מהמילים בו כל אחד מכן מילים או אני כולל כאן גם סימני פיסוק וכל מיני תווים אחרים.
אז היינו רוצים לכל אחד מהם לתת איזושהי קטגוריה מתוך אוסף סגור של קטגוריות שנקרא להם חלקי, דיבר Part of Speech, שבעצם משקפת את השימוש הספציפי הזה.
כן, אז למשל Profit זה אולי יכול להיות כן פועל, כמו כן מרוויח, אבל גם יכול להיות רווחים במקרה כאן זה רווחים,
אז היינו רוצים לסמן אותו ב n ובמקרים אחרים שבהם הוא יהיה מרוויח מסומן בוי.
אוקיי, ואנחנו מנסים להעלות כמה שיותר את הקושי שלנו, כלומר את הדיוק של הפרי דיקציה.
את מספר המילים בשרשרת שעבורן חזינו את הקטגוריה בצורה נכונה מתוך סך כל המילים.
אוקיי, אז זה part speech staging. שאלות לפני שזה אוקיי, אז זה פעם הספיד staging.
ודיברנו על זה שבעצם יש לנו כמה מקורות מידע אפשריים מקור מידע אחד שפחות נדבר עליו.
עכשיו נגיע אליו אחר כך. זה כל מיני פיצ'רים, אותו גרפים או מורפולוגי, מה שנקרא.
כמו כן, איך המדיה כתובה? כן, אם יש בה נקודות, אם היא כתובה כמו אות נקודה, אות נקודה.
אות נקודה כמו your נקודה S נקודה A כנראה שזה ראשי תיבות.
כך כותבים ראשי תיבות באנגלית הכל ממס ואם יש בה ואם היא מתחילה באחד תשעה וארבעה מספרים או בשתיים אפס וארבעה מספרים,
אז אולי זה יהיה שנה בסיכוי מסוים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז יש מידע גם בצורה שבה מילה כתובה, אבל אנחנו נניח לזה כרגע בצד.
אוקיי, כרגע אנחנו נסתכל פשוט על מילים, אינדקסים, אוקיי, לצרכינו.
ואז בעצם נוצרים שני סוגי שני מקורות מידע עיקריים שעל פיהם אנחנו רוצים לבסס את הפרי האחד מהם זה wait קבלת Is,
כלומר איזה מילים מתאימות לאילו קטגוריות ונתנו דוגמאות נכון אתם אולי זוכרים?
נגיד המשפט כאן מסביר יכול להיות שהם פרטיים, נכון?
יכול להיות? מה עוד? שבעצם כן, נכון.
כמו חשבון. כאילו מה הוא עוד יכול להיות פועל?
נכון שבעברית היינו אומרים את זה? מחייב?
כן. אוקיי. מחייב וכן הלאה. שורה אמרנו יכול להיות, רק ראיתי כאילו ראה.
כלומר פועל בעבר יכול להיות פועל בהווה שאומר מנסר יכול להיות מסור, כלומר נע או וכן הלאה.
והרבה מילים באנגלית הם ככה אגב, לא רק באנגלית.
בהרבה מאוד שפות, והיינו רוצים בעצם.
להבין איזה מילים מתאימות לאיזו קטגוריה. כלומר, אידיאלית לא רק אילו קטגוריות אפשריות עבור כל מילה, אלא גם ממש מה ההתפלגות שהם מופיעות בקטגוריות השונות.
כי אולי יש קטגוריות מסוימות נדירות יותר מאחרות, נכון? ונתנו את הדוגמה של Man שכנראה ברוב המקרים יופיע.
כך שבעצם נכון, אבל אולי לפעמים יופיע כי הוא פועל נכון, אבל כנראה ברוב ההקשרים זו הרבה יותר נדירה.
כן כן. נכון, זה בדיוק מה שמשוחק מרבית בשוק הזה, לפחות אם נדמה לי וזה לא, אז זה לא בהכרח נכון.
כי בעצם אתה מדבר כאילו שפה שמשתמשת בשורשים, שורשים ותבניות זמנים, וזה בימים חמים יותר בתוך מילה אחת.
כן, אז אוקיי, אז דבר ראשון לפעמים זה נכון, אבל זה יוצר לך א.
עדיין והרבה פעמים נשאר מידה לא מבוטלת של ביוטי.
נגיד למשל היא תגיד ואתה תגיד נכון, זה שתי הטיות שונות, אבל כאילו מאיזושהי סיבה ועברית לא היה הרבה סדר.
הרבה דברים נכון, משתנים, משנים, אבל כאילו זה דבר אחד.
דבר שני זה זה יכול לייצר הרבה.
תיזכרי בעצם נכון כמו. כמו למשל איך עושים את הסגמנטים בדיוק בתוך זה?
כן, בתוך המילה. אז נגיד למשל אתה יכול להסתכל על המילה נגיד.
כן, יש רהוט צרפתי מבר אילן עובדת הרבה על עברית ואוהבת לתת את חשבת הדוגמה הזאת?
כן. אז מה? אז מה זה היה? איך הייתם מנתחים את זה?
תלוי בקונטקסט. נכון? מה זה יכול להיות גם?
אז מה כתוב כאן? זו אפשרות אחת.
כלומר שם פרטי. נכון, שם של אלגרו.
אה אוקיי, יפה. שנייה אחת. נו, זה כבר שניים, נכון? אז אחד מהם אומר זה פשוט שם פרטי, שם של ארגון.
כן. השני אומר יש כאן שתי מילים אחת מילת יחס.
והשנייה שם עצם.
כאילו קובנר מה שנבחר נכון. Command שם נקרא לזה שם העצם.
עוד רעיונות. נכון, הבצל שלהם בצלם.
כן, לא מאוד נפוץ אבל. Out of art of קונטקסט.
צלם נכון? על זה בעצם תתעסק בנטייה כזאת.
ואומר החלק הזה הוא מה יש שם עצם והשני שייכות.
כן, כינוי שייכות קוראים לזה עושה סנכרון. יש עוד בצילם.
נכון? איך לדוגמה לצחצח שיניים איתו פשוט לא לשים מטריה במקום זה מילה?
לא, אבל הפעיל. אוקיי, אז אתה אומר באיזושהי רמה אפשר לעשות רדוקציה של זה לסגמנט טקסיות, אבל.
אוקיי, אז אז דבר ראשון אני מסכים איתך הרבה פעמים שאת הסגמנט תציע ושאלת הדריסה בקרואטיה היא מאוד קשורות אחת לשנייה,
אבל אם אנחנו נחשוב קצת, אני בטוח שנצליח לחשוב על מקרים שבהם גם עם אותה סגמנטים היה אתה מקבל כמה זמן עכשיו לחשוב על זה?
אולי כן זה לא. לא אמור להיות קשה? בסדר.
כן. אוקי, אולי דוגמה? דוגמה בעברית שהיא מאוד טיפוסית.
כן, זה הנושא של בינוני נכון? בינוני כמו שומר, פועל, אוכל לא יודע כן וכן הלאה.
מורא נכון יכול להיות גם פועל בזמן הווה וגם שם עצם, ויש כאלה שטוענים שהוא מין סוג של מצב ביניים ביניהם.
טוב, זה כבר לא ניכנס יותר מדי בלשנות, אבל כן.
אגב, קיבלתי בקשה בסוף השיעור הקודם.
אני חושב שהיא לא נמצאת כאן לדון בהמשך הקורס על סגמנטים.
קצת כאילו על סליחה, על חלוקה של מילים או של דברים שכתובים יחד לחתיכות.
כן, בין אם זה עסק מדיטציה, כמו למשל בסינית ששם כותבים בלי רווחים, כן את המילים ואז צריך להחליט איפה בעצם מתחילה מילה ואיפה נגמרת מילה.
בין אם זה כמו בעברית ששאלה שכזאת של כמה מילים זה מורכב ואיפה זה מתחיל ואיפה זה נגמר.
ועד השאלה היותר טכנית של פשוט איך מודלי שפה מחליטים מתי לחלק את זה לתוכן נפרד ומתי לא.
אז אני אגיד על זה ככותרת. בגדול אני בדרך כלל לא מעביר על הנושא הזה שיעור, למרות שיש יום מאוד מעניין לדעתי,
אבל אני כן יש לי בסוף הקורס ככה איזה שני שיעורים נראה אם השנה זה יצא שניים אולי זה יצא אחד עם הקיצוץ שעושים 10.
על כל פנים יש לי קצת חופש בסוף. אז אם יש לכם הצעות מתחרות או שאתם רוצים לתמוך בשיעור בנושא סגמנטים וכאלה, אז תכתבו לי.
אוקיי, אז אנחנו רוצים בעצם לקחת בחשבון שני דברים כן, שני אלמנטים עיקריים אחד מהם זה מה שקראנו ווי פור פילאטיס או וורד קלאס, פה פילאטיס.
והשני זה הקטגוריות של מילים סמוכות.
כן או אפשר להגיד באופן יותר כללי כמה השרשרת.
הקטגוריות לכשעצמה היא סבירה או לא סבירה, נכון ואמרנו יש שרשראות שהם סבירות, אולי מבחינת השרשרת,
אבל הן לא סבירות מבחינת איזה מילים מתאימות לכם, איזה התאמה של המילים כאילו ווטאבר בפילאטיס יש כאלה שלהפך, נכון?
אז למשל אין שום בעיה מבחינת הברור פה ובילתי להניח שזה פועל לחייב.
נכון, זה פועל בהווה, נגיד נכון, מנסר זה דטרמיניסטי, כלומר הזה זה פועל יש ואתמול רק שזה לא ממש שמשפטים בדרך כלל לא בנויים ככה.
לפחות באנגלית. כן כרצף של ורבר בתר מינרווה או Headstart.
בדרך כלל אחרי מידע יגיע שם עצם או את שיכתיב כן, כמו בטול Horse, DAT, טול Horse וכן הלאה באטמן וכולי.
אז הירוק אולי בסדר מבחינת ההתאמה של המילים לקטגוריה.
סליחה, איזה מהם הסתכלתי?
כן, אולי הירוק הוא אולי בסדר מבחינת ההתאמה של המילים לקטגוריות.
הוא לא בסדר מבחינת הרצף הכחול הוא כן בסדר מבחינת רצף הקטגוריות.
אז למשל, כתבתי את הדוגמה שאני חושב, אבל בוא ננסה לחשוב עליה.
נגיד למשל. הנה Find אוקיי find מרי before coming back או משהו כזה כן או Find?
פוקסי אז בפברואר coming back או משהו כזה. בסדר, זה בסדר מבחינת הרצף, אבל מה לעשות man פה הוא הולך עם ו שזה לא כל כך נפוץ.
אוקיי, אז היינו רוצים איכשהו לקחת את הבאלאנס של שניהם.
אבל מה הבעיה בלקחת בחשבון את מה שהוא שם שכלל את שניהם אפריורית?
לפחות מה מרחב האיתות, מה מרחב האפשרויות לתיוג?
בוא נחזור לזה. כמה תיוגים אפשריים יש לי כאן עבודה.
כמספר קטן, מספר קטגוריות בחזקת מספר מילים.
בעצם נכון, עם הירידה הקודמת שלך אני כבר עם הטיפוס.
אוקיי. בסדר, אז אני יכול לצמצם לחצי מיליון אחוז.
רק בגלל החוקים המעודכנים. נכון, ומסתבר שזה עדיין מספר עצום עבור נגיד משפטים באנגלית.
נגיד בקורפוס של עיתונות בסדר גודל של 20 תוכנס למשפט בממוצע יש גם כאלה יותר עורכי דין.
אז אתה מבין שדי מהר נכנס פה לבעיות מאוד רציניות, אפילו אם אתה מצמצם באופן אדיר, אז בקיצור,
הבעיה היא שיש כאן מספר עצום של תיוגים אפשריים, ואז אפשר לומר אוקיי, זה כיוון ראשון יגיד בסדר, הבנתי.
אבל בוא לא נסתבך פה יותר מדי.
אומנם הייתי שמח לדעת מה הקטגוריה של המילה לפני ואחרי כדי לשפוט האם התיוג הזה טוב או לא,
אבל בקרוב אני אניח שטוב זה לי להסתכל על המילים שנמצאות לפניי ואחרי ואחרי בסדר.
אז למשל כדי לסווג את המילה סו אז אני אראה שלפניה יש את ג'ון ואחרי שזה בסדר ואז אומנם אני לא יודע שזה שם פרטי ואחריו בטרמינל.
אוקיי, אבל בכל זאת זה נותן לי די הרבה אינפורמציה כי כנראה ג'ון כן.
מה זה כבר יהיה וזה מה זה כבר יהיה. וכן הלאה. אוקיי, אז זה אולי נשמע כמו משהו סביר, אבל לפעמים זה מאבד אינפורמציה.
נכון, למשל, אם יש לי מילים שהם ענו Words, נכון?
נגיד שעכשיו יש לי מילים שלא נתקלתי בהם בטרי נגדית ובוא ניזכר כן, אנחנו בסופר.
ויי setting כן, כלומר training data שלי זה כבר לא כמו קודם.
בלי Huge model שהיה לי גרזי.
ליון עדיין לפעמים זה לא הספיק לי לחלק מהדברים כן, אבל עדיין, אולי אפשר היה להניח שיש לי מיליארדי to change להתאמן עליהם כאן זה כמה שנים ידנית.
ישבתי וכתבתי אתה באיזושהי דרך את התשובות.
כן, יש גבול כמה הייתי יכול לעשות את זה, בטח על דומיין טיפה נישתי, על שפה.
אולי לא נורא מרכזית וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. כן, אז בהחלט ענווה.
Words זה דבר מאוד נפוץ, אלא אם איכשהו היה לי מלא מלא כסף לבזבז על תיוג ולכן זאת בעיה.
הדבר השני אולי דווקא איזה Sense פחות שגרתי של המילה נכון?
אוקיי, אז ברור שזה מאבד משהו. לא נראה אידיאלי, אבל זאת אפשרות.
אוקיי, כן, בכל הסדר של כמה אני מאוד ספציפי.
כן כן, אני אסביר. כן, כשאתה מתנסח מה התפקיד שלי, כן, אז אני אסביר.
אז בוא נגיד למשל שאני עכשיו נגיד מנסה לסווג את המילה סליחה, נגיד, אני מנסה לסווג את המילה טוב אנד בפני עצמו.
כנראה מילה לא יותר מדי. אתה יודע, big US אבל טוב, לא משנה.
בוא נניח שאנחנו מסתכלים עליה. אוקיי, ואתה רוצה לקחת בחשבון מצב טיסה איידס?
אוקיי, ובוא נגיד שיסיידו ענו World אז עכשיו יש לך פיצ'ר שאומר המילה אחריך היא בסיידר.
נכון? הפיצ'ר הזה עכשיו נדלק מופעל, אבל אין לך שום Data על הפיצ'ר הזה.
כן, כי הוא מעולם לא הופיע בקשרים עם Data. אז אוקיי, אז מה קורה?
כי אנדו זה אז בוא נקרא. אז בוא ננסה לקחת. אולי בוא ננסה לקחת איזשהי דוגמה אחרת אם אנחנו רוצים לעשות לך או פשוט לעשות סיפור עוד משהו.
הסתברותי ממקרה למקרה.
מה הכוונה הסתברותי? טוב? לפעמים אתה אומר נכון.
אם אני מתייחס למילה צריך להוריד את הכמות המינימלית למרות שאני בעד.
בסדר אם אתה. לא יודע.
אני מאמינה שהסגירה של אמא שלי כן.
אז בוא נגיד שהיה לנו כאן נגיד And לא יודע מה זה decided.
אוקיי, ואז יש לו כן שתי משמעויות. נכון שלא כמו אין בכל שוק.
אני לא מבינה כאילו הן אומרות זה בעייתי דווקא בהקשר זה.
לא, כי אוקיי, כי בוא בוא נחשוב על זה. כפית של הפרזנטציה יש.
אם כן, אתה עכשיו מסתכל על המילה הזאת, שאף עריכה ויש פיצ'ר שמקודד אותה.
נכון שאומר המילה אחריי היא decided. עכשיו אני רוצה לקבוע מאפרת שלי.
הפיצ'ר הזה נותן לך שום אינפורמציה. עכשיו אתה אומר אתה יכול להשתמש במשהו אחר.
אז אני אשאל אותך במה. גם כשאתה נתקלתי מה תעשה כל מוצר?
שמע, אבל אומר מה קרה מהמודלים לגראמי? מה הקטגוריה הכי סבירה ולחזור על מילים לפני?
סלאש. אה, בסדר. רק מילה אחת מסכימה עם כל מילה שאמרת.
לא רגע, זה לא תינוקות, זה קלסי? פיקציה? כן? אז אתה אומר בעצם אני יכול.
תראה, באופן כללי אנחנו גם נדבר על זה תכף כבי סלייד.
כן, תכף נדבר על זה. באופן כללי אתה היית יכול לגמרי להתעלם מהקונטקסט וללכת רק על וורוד פה בבלט.
אז זה, מסתבר. בישראל לא כל כך קל בהרבה הקשרים כן, כי לרוב המילים הם לא כמו Back.
כן, אנגלית אפילו אני אומר בוא נדבר. אנגלית היא שפה עם כל מיני מאפיינים די ייחודיים, אבל אני לוקח משם את הדוגמאות כרגע, כי כן, ככה המצגת.
אבל נגיד המילה back באמת אמרנו שיש לה איזה ארבעה party speech שכולם לא נראים נורא נדירים.
נכון, ראינו את זה בשיעור שעבר ורוב המילים יש להם מחלקה דומיננטית ואז אתה יכול להגיד אני מתעלם מהקונטקסט.
אני פשוט מתייג את המילה במוסד ללייבל שלה.
כן, אז אנחנו גם נדבר על הבי סלאם הזה. בסדר, וגם אני רוצה שתיקחו בחשבון כאן עוד משהו.
כן, שאנחנו משתמשים בפרטי speech staging כבעיית כתב איזשהו מקרה.
מקרה מבחן מקרה שאנחנו משתמשים בו כהסבר.
אבל בעצם יש כל מיני בעיות.
יש כל מיני בעיות שאנחנו היינו רוצים להשתמש באותה אלגוריתמיקה כדי לפתור.
כן, ואנחנו דיברנו למשל על הנושא של לינדן סטטי בשיעור הקודם.
אם אתם זוכרים נכון שאמרנו שאנחנו רוצים לסווג, לזהות איפה יש named entity is ולהגיד איזה סוג הם.
אז כאן כן, כנל.
בהחלט יכולים להיות בהחלט יכולים להיות הרבה.
אנו words, לדעת את המילה של לפני ואחרי כן אולי לא מספיק עוזר לי כי זה כי זה מילה על node או כי יש לה כמה מובנים.
כן, נגיד למשל לא יודע אם אנחנו מסתכלים על.
נגיד מקרים שהם named entity,
אז הרבה מהשמות של החברות הם גם שמות של כן שמות פרטיים נכון כמו נגיד Apple זה אולי כן
חברה הכי גדולה כזאת או אינטל Intel זה גם קיצור של כאילו מודיעין כזה Intelligence נכון?
וכן הלאה. אז אז ככה שהדברים האלה הם לא נכונים רק לגבי Parts.
טוב, אז זה כיוון אחד כיוון טיפה יותר מתוחכם זה להגיד טוב בסדר.
אני צריך לדעת את הקטגוריה של המילה, אבל בהרבה מקרים אני יכול לדעת מה הקטגוריה של המילה נגיד.
למשל אם אני, אם אני מסתכל נגיד על המילה gun, אז מאוד סביר להניח שאת ספציפית את המילה ג'ון.
אין לה כל כך הרבה guest, ולכן אותה אני כן הצליח לסווג עם Class נכון?
אוקיי, אבל אחרי זה כשאני עובר למילה סוף, אני יכול כבר להתנות בפרטי speed שחזיתי, כלומר לעשות את לעשות את החיזוי הזה סדרתית,
לחזות את הקטגוריה של הראשון, להשתמש בו כפיטר השני והשלישי אני כבר יכול להשתמש אולי בשני הקודמים ובסדר וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
וכל פעם אני בעצם יכול כבר לנצל את הפרי. דיג ציות שעשיתי זה יוצר תלות ביניהם.
נכון, כל פעם באפליקצייה אין לי את, אני יכול להסתמך על הקודמות.
כן, גם אתה פרופ הראשון. אוקיי, נכון.
אז דבר ראשון יש עניין של קסקדה, של טעויות. נכון? אולי טעיתי איפשהו בדרך, אבל עכשיו תהיה לי את האות F.
טעות מתגלגלת. אז זה בעיה אחת. עוד בעיה זה לא קיים בעצם.
דברים כאלה נפוצים בחלקים השונים של המשפט שיהיו עקביות מול האיכויות של כן או דרך
יותר כללית אולי להגיד את זה זה שלפעמים דווקא המידע החשוב נמצא לפני ולא מאחורי כן.
אז בוא ניקח למשל דוגמה. כן.
אז בואו למשל ניקח דוגמה. נגיד שאנחנו רוצים עכשיו, למשל, לסווג את לסווג את המילה, לסווג את את.
אתם רואים שיש שתי two במשפט גם decided to take it וגם to the table.
נכון, יש ביניהם הבדל מבחינת פארדו Speech. איך הייתם מתרגמים אותם לעברית?
נגיד את השני? איך הייתם מתורגמים לעברית? אין נכון עולה ואת הראשון זה לא בדיוק ברור שיש לו תרגום.
כן, זה חלק פשוט מצורת הבסיס של נכון צורת הבסיס של מה שנקרא.
פרימיטיבית. באנגלית אם בסדר אז אחלה.
איך מבדילים ביניהם? סך הכל יש דרך די פשוטה הנה, הנה ניתן לכם כלל אצבע.
אוקיי, אם מופיע אחרי זה אחרי המילה הזאת נה או עוד Terminal.
כן, כמו זה או כמו לא יודע מה ג'רוזלם או משהו כזה, אז כנראה מה זה הטור הזה?
אין. ואם מופיע אחריו Nowhere סליחה אחריו בצורת הבסיס.
אז כן, זה הסיפור. אז השני.
כן. אז. אז אוקיי. אז איפה נמצאת האינפורמציה החשובה?
אם ככה, כדי להכריע האם זה טור כזה אותו כזה בדיוק אחרי?
נכון. ובאופן כללי תיתקלו במקרים שבהם בחלק האינפורמציה החשובה היא אחראי וחלק לפנאי.
אז מה אתם עושים? איך משקללים את זה? אוקיי.
בקיצור, לא נראה רק בצורה מאוד principles. לפחות לא צורה מאוד כללית לענות על הבעיה.
אנחנו צריכים משהו יותר טוב. משהו יותר מספק שיכול לתת לנו פרי דיקציה מהימנה שלוקחת בחשבון את התלויות בין הקטגוריות.
אז מה נעשה? נחזור כן למודל ההסתדרותי החביב עלינו, שהוא בעצם מודלים הרקובים.
כן. שאתם עוד זוכרים מהשיעור הקודם ולשכלל אותו קצת כדי שבעצם יוכל לעבוד כאן כמודל לפני דיקציה סדרתית.
אז איך זה יעבוד? אז בעצם ככה נראה המודל.
המודל הראשון שאנחנו נציג. הוא יהיה מודל גן נרטיבי.
אוקיי. מישהי או מישהו יכולים להזכיר לנו מה זה מודל גן נרטיבי?
ממדרגה ראשונה. אוקיי, נכון.
אז זהו מודל ההסתברות המשותפת. האיקסים אנחנו נסמן אותם באופן כללי בקורס הזה זה מוטציה מקובלת, זה יהיה Observer ויהיה פרלס.
כן, כאילו הדברים שאיתם אנחנו באים אנחנו יכולים לצפות גם בתסריט הקמפיין Nature והוואי, אם זה הלייבל.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו בעצם יש לנו סדרה של INPUT עם איקס אחד.
אם ואנחנו מנסים לתת הסתברות משותפת לסדרה הזאת ולסדרת לייבל, אז כן, שמתאימה אחד לאחד האינדקסים, לא?
אז וכרגיל אנחנו בדרך כלל נניח שגם יש לנו איזשהו סטופ בהתחלה כן בסוף וסטארט בהתחלה כן,
תכף אתם תבינו איפה זה נכנס, אבל זה לגמרי סטנדרטי כמו שראינו במודל A שפה יפה.
ועכשיו איך אנחנו הולכים להניח שנראה את ההתפלגות הזאת?
אנחנו הולכים להניח שיש לה צורה מסויימת. אוקיי?
של התפלגות המשותפת של האיקסים והוואי האם מתפרקת?
מתפרקת. כך מתפרקת כמכפלה על ההסתברויות של הוואי.
כלומר כן. בעצם אנחנו הולכים להניח שהגויים הם שרשרת מרקוב כרגע מסדר ראשון, כמו שכתוב כאן.
כן, אפשר גם להכליל את זה. אנחנו הופכים להניח שווים הלייבלים.
הם מהווים שרשרת מרקוב ואנחנו הולכים להניח שבעצם כל אחד מהם איקס.
האם נדגם מהוואי, כלומר הוא בלתי תלוי בכל האיקסים האחרים ובכל הווים האחרים, בהינתן הקטגוריה שלה?
אוקיי, שזאת תהיה תכף אנחנו נראה. זאת ההנחה הרבה יותר רדיקלית מהם.
כן, מהראשון מהנחת המון קוביות ואנחנו נרצה גם להיפטר ממנה תכף, אולי בשיעור הבא.
על כל פנים, ככה נראה מודל. אז בוא ננסה טיפה להבין איזה כן.
איזה הנחות. נראה את זה ממש מתמטית. אז ההנחות הגלומות בו אין כמו לעשות את זה על הלוח.
אז אנחנו בעצם אומרים אנחנו מגדירים מודל הסתברותי כן שנותן הסתברות לסדרת האיקסים.
לסדרת ה y. כרגיל אנחנו, אנחנו מפרקים את זה כמה שתמיד אפשר לעשות כן, כי prior על סדרת ה הוואי כפול ההסתברות של האובזרבר.
בהינתן ה y, ככה בדרך כלל עושים מודלים נראטיבים אז ה ph של ה y.
כפול P של האיקסים. בהינתן while.
אוקיי, ועכשיו מגיעות ההנחות שלנו. אז דבר ראשון אנחנו הולכים להניח שהגויים האלה הם מהווים שרשרת מרקוב.
כלומר ניתן לכתוב את הY אם כ. מה ההסתברות המשותפת על פני כל הוואי, הרי אורל, הוואי.
בשרשרת מכובדת מסדר ראשון. מה ההסתברות של השרשרת?
הזאת בדיוק? אנחנו מניחים שבעצם מה שמשנה זה רק המעברים.
מה לוקאלי נכון? שרשרת של פאתוס פיצ'י טובה היא תקפה.
אם כל אחד מהמעברים הוא טוב. כן.
אם הממוצע, לפחות הממוצע ההנדסי של המעברים שלה מתחיל להידרדר אז גם ההסתברות תרד.
אבל זה לא קשור לאיזשהו קשר רחוק בין בין הY הראשון לבין שבסוף.
זה הכל בטווח, דרך קשרים לא קל. אוקיי, אם כל המעברים הלא קלים הם בסדר, אז גם השרשרת בסדר, אז אנחנו מניחים שזה הסתברות.
כן, סימנתי את זה כאן כקיום. פשוט כי יש לנו כאן שני סוגי הסתברויות.
אז וואי i בהינתן Wii מינוס אחד והרבה פעמים מניחים גם stop וסטאר וזה כל הדברים הרגילים.
איי שווה אחד. אם נגיד או אם פלוס אחד אם יש לי סטוק.
ואני מניח לגבי זה כן.
לגבי האיקסים שני הדגמים על ידי ה y זה שאני מניח שכל אחד מהאקסים האלה נכון.
איך? איך זה היה תיאורטית צריך להיות זה איקס אחד בהינתן כל הY כפול x 2 בהינתן איקס אחד וכל הY כפול איקס שלוש, בהינתן איקס אחד ואיקס שתיים וכל ה y,
ואני פשוט הולך להניח שהדבר היחידי שמעניין אותי מכל שאר השרשרת כדי לדעת מה ההסתברות של האיקס המסוים הזה בתיוג הזה, זה פשוט אותו הY הספציפי.
איך הוא עצמו מתויג בסדר, אז אנחנו מניחים שזה מכפלה של i שווה אחד עדין של ההסתברות שקראתי לה אי כאן, אבל זה עדיין הסתברות.
כי זה פשוט קיצור של Mission. הם.
Mission זה ייקרא function. מאיפה השמות האלה הגיעו?
אז כן, זה נראה לי יחסית ברור. נכון, דיברנו על זה מודלים מקובעים.
אני חושב על זה, כי מצבים שאני עובר ביניהם בכל מצב אחד אחרי זה, בשלב הבא אני מחליף מצב אחד.
אתה מחליף מצב? כן, אתה כותב וכן הלאה. אז זה הצ'אנס של האמי שם?
כן, הסתברות הפליטה זה. אז נגיד אתם יכולים לחשוב על זה.
זה נגיד הרבה קשרים שחשבו על זה לאורך הזמן.
זה למשל בוא נניח שאני עכשיו הולך.
אתם זוכרים את ההליכה המקרית רנדומלית? כן, שדיברנו בהקשר של משהו.
מר קובי, נכון, אני נמצא איפשהו בחלל.
אתם יודעים, נגיד איפה נקודת ההתחלה שלי, ואחרי זה אני בכל שלב מחליט לזוז, נגיד ימינה, שמאלה.
אולי גם לא משנה. בוא נגיד ימינה או שמאלה כדי לפשט את זה עכשיו בוא נניח שיש עליי משדר.
כן, יש עליי משדר. אתם לא ממש יכולים לראות אותי באופן בלתי אמצעי.
אוקיי, אלא אתם רק קולטים כל מיני שדרים שאני מוסר דרך המשדר.
רק מה לעשות, יש הרבה רעש ואני משדר לכם ממאדים או משהו כזה וכל מיני פירנס וכן הלאה.
ואתם לא מקבלים בדיוק סיגנל מדויק של איפה אני נמצא, אלא אתם מקבלים אותו יחד עם רעש מסוים.
אוקיי, במקרה הזה ההנחה הזאת נשמע סך הכל די הגיונית.
נכון, יש לי איזשהו משדר מסוים? כן, בהינתן שאני נמצא באיזשהו מצב, בכל מצב שאני יכול להיות בו, יש לי איזשהי הסתברות.
בעצם או לכם יש איזשהי הסתברות מסוימת לקלוט איזשהו שדר מסוים לגבי המיקום שלי, אבל אתם לא ממש רואים את Wii נכון?
אתם לא ממש רואים את המצב שלי. אני על מאדים, אבל אתם מקבלים איזשהו שדר, אולי רואש, ואני מניח שהשדה הזה תלוי רק במיקום שממנו שידרתי.
כן או לא? תלוי איפה הייתי קודם. הוא לא תלוי בי.
כן, לא.
השדרים הקודמים שקיבלתם ממני, לא באיפה באמת הייתי קודם, לא תלוי בחלל, אלא יש איזושהי התפלגות שקשורה לרעש שנמצא ספציפית במקום המסוים שאני נמצא בו, נכון?
אז זה נשמע תחת ההנחה הזאת של מין משדר כזה שאתם מקבלים זה סיגנל מרשים.
זה נראה כמו מודל די מתקבל על הדעת עכשיו. כן, נכון.
אז זה נשמע סביר. אנחנו תכף נראה שבמקרה שלנו זה לא הנחה כל כך מתקבלת על הדעת.
אבל בסדר כמודל זה נקודה טובה להתחיל ממנה. בסדר.
אז שאלות לגבי זה? לגבי המודל עצמו. אוקיי, יפה, אז זה המודל, אמר קובי החבור.
כן, העידן מרקוב מודל או בקיצור ATM. למה הוא נקרא מודל מקווי חבוי?
מקווה שכבר נשמע הגיוני בשלב הזה. נכון יש מודל מר קובי זה ה Y.
אנחנו לא צופים בו ישירות. אנחנו צופים מאיזשהו מסר שמגיע ממנו.
כן, שתלוי במצב שבו כן ההילוך המקרי הזה נמצא.
בסדר ומודלים רקובים כמובן. אנחנו זוכרים אותם וזה מודל מרקוב מסדר ראשון, ואפשר כמובן גם להעלות מסדר יותר גבוה.
אז איכשהו נשמט כאן סליחה, אני אוסיף try גם אני אכתוב את זה על הלוח כזה.
אני אתקן את השקופית. טייק המודל זה מאוד דומה.
ההבדל היחידי הוא שאני צריך להשתנות על הכל משני הכיוונים.
בעצם אני מסתכל עכשיו השלישיות צמודות סטרייק כאן.
מהם פשוט נראה כך. בסדר, יש לו גם את ההתניה לאדום.
חוץ מזה אותו דבר אפשר לחשוב גם על הסדרים יותר. בסדר, עכשיו בוא נסתכל על ההנחות האלה בהקשר של Part of Speech State.
כן, כי אמרנו אולי המשוואות מתקבלות על הדעת. אם אני מין רכב מאדים כזה.
נכון שנוסע במאדים ומשדר כל מיני שדרים לגבי המיקום שלו, אבל זה לא המצב אצלנו אצלנו אנחנו הולכים להניח שהוא קיים.
מה? קטגוריה בכל הקטגוריות דקדוקיות של המילים זה האיקסים הם המילים עצמן.
נכון שאותם אנחנו. בהם אנחנו צופים המוחזר, אז בוא נראה בעצם מה אנחנו מניחים.
אז אז אנחנו בעצם מניחים שני דברים אחד זה ההנחה ששרשרת הפרט או Speech שרשרת חלקי הדיבר עם הקוביות.
כן, זה הנחה השנייה שכתובה כאן. וההנחה הראשונה זה כמו שאמרנו האמת.
Value האיקס i הוא בלתי תלוי בכל שאר המשתנים בהינתן Y אז דבר ראשון כן.
אז נתחיל מההנחה שמסתבר פחות בעייתית בהקשר הזה שזאת ההנחה השנייה.
אז כרגיל, דיברנו על זה גם בהקשר של מודלי שפה מקובעים.
השפה עצמה היא לא מקובעת תמיד. נכון, היא לא מרקוביץ באמת.
יש תלויות אוקיי ארוכות טווח. אפילו נגדיל את הסדר של המודל.
כנראה לא נצליח לתפוס באמת את כי לא הצליח לתפוס באופן כללי את כל סוגי דיפרנציאלי, כי חלקם מאוד רחוקים.
מי שלא זוכר מציע מפנה אתכם לדיון שלנו במרחב Language Model.
זה היה בדיוק אותו רעיון, אבל מסתבר שזה איכשהו בסדר, כי לפחות לגבי חלק מהפרטים קצת לגבי שפה, ומסתבר שחלקי דיבר, הם די נכללות בזה.
רוב הפריטים קצת הם די לוקאלית. אוקיי, זאת אומרת, הזהות של המילים הקרובות יחסית של חלקי.
הדבר הקרובים יחסית הם מי שמשפיע יותר, ולכן זה לא נכון להגיד שהשרשרת הזאת באמת מתפרקת כמכפלה,
נגיד על ההסתברויות, מעברים, טריגרים יות, אבל זה איזשהו קירוב מתקבל על הדעת.
אוקיי, ההנחה היותר בעייתית היא ההנחה השנייה.
כן, ההנחה שבעצם אומרת שהזהות של המילה היא בלתי תלויה בכל שאר המשתנים בהינתן הקטגוריה שלה, והסיבה לזה היא די פשוטה.
כן, הסיבה לזה היא שבעצם זה שאני, אפילו אם הקטגוריות שלי הם כן הם יחסית עדינות.
זאת אומרת, הם לא סתם פועל שם עצם כן,
אלא אני יכול להגיד זה פועל בזמן עבר בהטיית גוף ראשון יחיד או זה שם עצם שהוא לא יודע מה שם קיבוצי כן או יחיד או רבים או משהו כזה.
כן, אפילו אם זה עדיין להגיד שההסתברות שלי לייצר מילה בלתי תלויה בשאר המילים במשפט שאני אוהב את הקטגוריה שלה זה די מוגזם, נכון?
אם אני יודע שהפועל במשפט הוא נבח אוקיי, ועכשיו אני מסתכל על הנושא.
כן, נגיד המילה שמופיעה לפניו, נגיד באנגלית, או כן הנאום המרכזי שמופיע לפניו.
ואני אומר לכם תגידו לי מה כתוב שם? מה X?
מה נראה לכם? כן, אז כנראה נכון, אבל אם זה אני לא יודע מה כתב אז אולי זה לא כן נכון, אלא משהו אחר.
כן, נשמע די טריוויאלי. כן, או כמה קצת לאפס.
כאילו חלף. נכון, חלף פועל כזה נכון של תכלס, מה משתמשים בו אחרת לזמן באנגלית נכון?
כאילו אומרים מה זה יהיה כבר דקות שניות. אילוץ מאוד חזק שלא קשור לקטגוריה של זה יכול להיות.
יכול להיות. אילת? כן.
כן. לא חלף. כן, אבל לילה. לא חושב.
כן, זהו חלף. זה לא תרגום מדויק כל כך. כאילו נתתי אז דוגמה די קיצונית.
אבל נכון, כי נבח אולי גם בן אדם. להפך. מי יודע, אולי לא יודע.
הכתב והפוליטיקאי נבח על חברי מפלגתו.
בסדר, אולי לא, אבל זה ממש לא. יש לפעמים ושרק שם זה מאוד קשה.
אוקיי, אז למה בכלל אנחנו מתעסקים ב שלב א?
כי אתם תראו שהעקרונות שאנחנו נלמד כאן הם הם יהיו רלוונטיים שנייה אחת.
הם יהיו רלוונטיים גם שנדבר על מודלים מתקדמים ומתוחכמים יותר, וגם מכך שזאת טכניקה שנראה לי חשוב שתיתקלו בה.
משתמשים בה בהרבה הקשרים. גם אם בתצפית יש כבר שיטות יותר חדשניות, נתקלים בהרבה קשרים וזה טכניקה חשובה ושימושית.
אולי חלקכם, נגיד אנשי הביולוגיה החישובית כאן, שאני לא זוכר מהם.
אה, כן, בטח נתקלת בזה או שתיתקל בזה. אה, כן, חפרתם על זה בלי סוף.
אוקיי, את השאלה. למה?
מובן שההשפעה אומר קובי כחלון לקונטקסט. התיאוריה וגם את הבעייתיות של המחקר, אבל לא לגמרי.
אה, אוקיי, אז בוא נסתכל ככה את הדוגמה שלך. כן, נמאס.
אז. אז כשמה שאת עושה יכול להיות קטע חוקי ומשם מתייחס רק לקטגוריה.
רק. נושא מי המציא את הכותב? אז מה? בוא נסתכל שנייה.
אוקיי, בוא ניקח איזושהי דוגמה פשוטה אוקיי, יש לנו פה, נגיד זה בעברית.
אוקיי, זה הדוגמה שנתתי, נגיד שם עצם, פועל וכולי.
זהו, אתה יודע מה? למה? למה להסתבך? בוא ניקח שניים פה יש לנו Start.
איפה יש לנו Stop? בסדר, אז זה הוואי?
כן, זה סדרת הוואי מסדרת האיקסים שלי.
היא כאן, יש לי עכשיו אני יודע שפה יש לי. את נבח נכון?
עכשיו אני רוצה להסתכל על העסק וכאן יש לי את X אחד.
כן, זה X 2 וואי 2 וואי אחד.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו אני רוצה להסתכל על. סליחה על ההסתברות של X אחד בהינתן שווי אחד הוא שם עצם.
ולהשוות אותה להסתברות של איקס אחד.
בהינתן שווי אחד שם עצם ואיקס שתיים שווה לנפח.
מההנחה של שרשראות מרקוב חבויות מה אני אם זה באמת נדגם בשרשרת?
מה פה? ואני יכול להגיד על שתי ההסתברויות האלה? שוות נכון?
בוא נחשוב על זה. יש לך. אני אומר לך שמה יש לך שם עצם במקום ראשון במשפט.
מה נראה לך? תן לי ניחוש, אל תסתכל, תן לי ניחוש מה תגיד?
מה עכשיו? מה מה מה מה, מה הוא, מה אני אומר לך?
יש עכשיו שם עצם שמתחיל משפט. בדיוק מי יודע בכלל.
הייתי זורק כל מיני דברים. כן, לא יודע, איש מדבר, לא יודע כל מיני.
כלב זה אחת האפשרויות, אבל לא יודע אם דווקא האפשרות הכי זה.
אבל אם היית יודע שזה נבח כנראה זה כבר ממש כלב.
כן? ואם היית יודע שזה כאילו ועכשיו אנחנו באנגלית שזה אלבסטה אז עכשיו זה סקר מזון, מין עץ או לא יודע?
Our מקסיקו כן, כאילו יש פה תלות מאוד חזקה.
כן, זה ממש משפיע על הכנסת עצמה.
לא רק כן בסדר. שאלות נוספות אוקיי, יפה, אז בסדר.
אז עכשיו אנחנו בעצם ניגשים לשאלת האינפלציה. אוקיי.
לשאלת העסק אמרנו שתמיד שאנחנו נגדיר מודלים הסתברותיים, אנחנו נרצה לדון באיך מוגדר המודל נכון.
איך בהינתן x ו y אם אנחנו נותנים הסתברויות, איך זה נראה?
מה ההנחות שזה מגלם? זה מה שעשינו עד כה. יש עוד שני אלמנטים שאנחנו נצטרך שהם למידה וזה בעסק.
אוקיי, נכון, בלי זה אין לנו הרבה מה לעשות. אז בוא נתחיל לדבר הפעם על נתחיל מעסק ונראה לי שבעיקר נדבר עליו אחרי ההפסקה.
אבל בוא נציג את הבעיה שעומדת מולנו ואחרי זה נחשוב מה הפתרון אחרי ההפסקה.
אז אנחנו אומרים יש לנו איזשהו input settings. נכון, אנחנו צופים בו והאופציה בבולים צריך להדביק.
אם יש לנו סדרת תגיות שמתאימה לעצים האלה, רק אותה אנחנו לא יודעים.
אנחנו מנסים לגלות מהי. יש לנו איזה שהוא מודל Home, נכון עידן מרקוס Model, שמסוגל בהינתן איזושהי השמה לאקסים והוואי להגיד לנו מה.
אז מה הסבירות? כן נכון? מה ההסתברות שהמודל נותן להם?
ומה שאנחנו רוצים למצוא זה את סדרת Y שבאמת נחזה שהיא פשוט האר מקס על פני כל סדרות הY של ההסתברות המשותפת של איקס אחד.
ווואי אחד הדברים נכון וכבר מהגדרה הזאת ברור שאנחנו נצטרך לעשות איזשהי עבודה כאן.
למה? למה זה לא פשוט?
תחשב את ההסתברויות ותבחר את המקסימום. אתה יכול לראות בדיוק את זה, למנות על כל האופציות מספר אדיר של אופציות.
אנחנו צריכים לעשות משהו קצת יותר מתוחכם ונעשה את זה אחרי הפסקה. כן, הסיפור של מכבי תל אביב עובר.
האם זה ההסתברות? אתם רואים? לא רק אתה רואה אותו ובישראל מוסיפים מה ההסתברות לקבל את זה?
לא תיארתי. לעצמי.
תזכור שאתה נותן את כל הרכיבים כאילו זה כמובן, אבל זה כבר אחרי שקיבלתי מוטציה.
אתה בעצם מסביר איך מייצרים את מה שנראה לי.
ואז אתה שואל אותי עכשיו אני מכיר את התבניות.
אני לא אומר לך מהו הרצף הזוטר ביותר, השם.
של התקין שיצא לך. בגלל זה כבר סדר פה הפוך זה XP אפרורי ולא בעייתי.
אתה עכשיו עשית את זה כאילו אתה חושב על הקלאסיקה.
מה זה אומר? בוא נתחיל עם הרעיון שלי, אבל כמו בניסוי, בואו נלך.
אל תסמוך עליי בסעיף ספורט או תחליט.
אנחנו עשינו פה הרבה ספורט, פוליטיקה וכלכלה, ובהינתן ההחלטה הזאת.
ואז אתה עושה ואז אתה עובד הפוך. פרץ אתה אומר עכשיו יש לך עבודה טובה.
רואים, נשארת בבית הספר. כן.
זאת אומרת, זה בדיוק כאילו להפוך את כיוון הגנת הצרכן על ידי חוק פייסבוק.
זה עוד לא דיברנו על קאנט, אבל מה זה בגדול?
למה סטרייטיות? קצת מחלקות?
לא. בטח לא עכשיו, חמישה. אני גם בטוח שיש קשרים.
כן. תראה, אנחנו נלמד מן הסתם ליתר דיוק. אבל א.
חלק מהמודלים אני לא בטוח שאתה לא יודע אנשי הצופים שם אולי אתה מפסיק את זה.
אז עכשיו לראות סרטונים חדשים? כן כן, היית שמן מן הסתם יהיה מאוד דומה למה שאתה זוכר, אבל כבר בשיעור הבא יש.
אז למה אנחנו סקפטיים לגבי תחקיר של הערוץ?
הראשון מול ישראל היום? כן. אז דבר שני אני חושב שאין דבר כזה.
אז מה? נעליים.
מדוע היא הייתה? למה לא?
לא הכרנו. עוסק השאלה.
מה זה? הקצב של.
שמעון פרס. שמעון פרס.
במקביל. אנשים מתקדמים.
אז נכנס אליי. אמרתי לו.
לא חזקים, חושבת אם צריך יותר.
אבל יש. השנה הבאה תהיה.
בכל מקרה החלק. טוב אתה מוכשר.
אביבית. אני לא הולך לשום דבר.
כי אני מכירה. נראה.
אל תתפלאו אם תהיו. צריך אותך?
זה היה קצת. כך אפשר לייצר.
המוטיבציה לא הייתה קיימת עד הסוף.
אינני יודע. וגם. כי לא יכולתי לישון צהריים כבר אחרי רעים עכשיו.
אז מה כן? כן, ואז כאילו בנקודות.
שתי החברות הבהירו. כי אפשר להשיג מוצרים שאינם מזיקים.
כן, אבל זה לא תלוי בזה.
אני לא חושבת שבשלב הזה כל כך טוב.
למצוא. לפני זמן לא היו יכולים להגיש.
למפכל המשטרה תמונות של הריסת דגל ישראל.
זה לא יכול. דבר נוסף שצריך לעשות.
אני רואה את התפיסה. אין לנו ילדים.
יסודות. ומה עם החזרה לארץ?
אז מה עושים? בכל מקרה, זה לא צריך משהו מיוחד.
עלות. אחלה של משהו. מנסה לעשות קצת סדר.
אם עדיין לא מים בכוס מים.
אם עדיין לא הבנתם את החשיבה החיובית.
יש לי כל כך הרבה. אני.
זו. אני מקווה כי עד עכשיו.
כשאני חוזר. יש לך אינטרס באמת.
הוא כל כך אוהב. לא.
כן. למי?
זה מתאים? לא רוצה לדעת. אני מקווה שאנשים לא זוכרים את הסיפור.
ברצינות ולא סתם. את.
הוא לא רצה. כאילו.
הוא רצה. זה היה יכול לא לעבוד.
אולי תחשבו קצת. וואו וואו, עשיתי את כל מה שיכולתי.
לאורך. כן.
זה. הלכתי על גשר חדש.
אני היה מלא דגים ואז.
כן היה ברשימה של הניו יורק טיימס.
הילד הזה יהיה יותר טוב ממה שאפשר. האם זה יעבוד?
לראשונה בשנת 2005. הצליח.
בוודאי שאפשר. רציתי להמליץ על קורס מדריכי שחייה.
זה מה שנשאר. 29.
מה הפלא שזה? לא.
מה שאתה היית עושה עכשיו הוא יש לי סכין בגב למרות שאתה לא.
אני מצפה יהיה.
עכשיו אני משתמש בכל הכוח. חוץ מזה אם יש לך.
לגבי הסכם עתידי. לא אני. חושב.
בקשר לזה אני שייך לתקופת זמן.
אני לוקחת ברצינות. את הסיפור עם האחות הקטנה בת ה 16.
מה קרה לה? תוך כמה זמן?
לפני. מספר שבועות קשה לעשות.
איזה. אוקיי.
אז. Influence.
בסדר. אז באופן עקרוני מה אנחנו צריכים לעשות?
כן, תיאורטית, כדי לבצע את האינפרה, מה שהיינו צריכים לעשות זה בעצם לקחת את סדרת האיקסים.
להוסיף להם בהתחלה בסדר איזשהו סטארט בסוף סטופ.
כן, אני מסמן כאן את Start בתור כוכבית.
אז תשימו לב שבעצם אנחנו צריכים פה start start כי זה טריגר model.
אז יש לנו איקס אפס ואיקס מינוס אחד. היינו צריכים לקחת את את האיקסים, להציב אותם בזה.
היינו צריכים להסתכל על כל הסדרות של Y אם לחשב את ההסתברות הזאת.
P של איקס אחד דיקסון וואי אחד. אין פלוס אחד כמכפלה על הטרנזיט שבהם Mission בפלט Is.
ובעצם למצוא את המקסימלי מבין כל האפשרויות עבור סדרת הY.
כן, אז כאן גם נתתי ממש דוגמה. כן.
אז בגדול, אם נגיד יש לכם X אחד X אחד x שתיים x 3 שזה דואג לאפס.
אוקיי, ויש לכם סדרה אפשרית במקרה הזה גם סדרה נכונה של parts speech text שזה The Terminal now עובד.
אז הצורה שבה ההסתברות הזאת הייתה מתפרקת היא דטרמיניסטית בהתחלה נגיד סדרת התגיות עכשיו זה שפה ביליתי אז בטרמינל.
בהינתן Start Start Now ואם ניתן Start בטרמינל ובהינתן טרמינל now stop בהינתן None טרמינל זה סוגר את זה שם ואז
יש משם ובהינתן The Terminal דווקא בהינתן Now let's בהינתן ואז היינו פשוט יכולים לקחת את הטבלאות שחישבנו,
כי אנחנו מניחים שמודל ה HTML ממומן בשלב הזה, כמובן.
אז היינו יכולים ללכת להסתכל על הטבלאות של הצ'אנס הישן.
מה ההסתברות לטרנד זה ישן בין Den לוי Start, לב an וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
וכנל לגבי הטבלאות שלהם. מי שם פה בלטינית ולחשב את ההסתברות הזאת?
מצוין. כן, לזה אני נראה לי.
אני דווקא אעבוד הפוך. אני אתחיל מאייפון. כן?
אז boot force יזכור פלסטלינה פישינג? כן, כמו שאמרנו אנחנו לא באמת יכולים לעבור על כל התגיות.
מה נעשה במקום הזה? אז בואו אני אציג לכם, אולי לפני שנכתוב את זה בצורה פורמלית, ממש אלגוריתם.
בוא נבין בעצם מה הרעיון כאן, כי זה סך הכל רעיון שאתם מכירים מקורס באלגוריתמים לפחות, בטח גם מעוד כמה מקומות שזה רעיון של תכנון דינמי.
אוקיי, אז איך זה עובד בעצם? בואו ניקח לצרכי פשטות Big רמות טריגרים אתם תראו, תכף עובד בצורה מאוד דומה.
אז בעצם אנחנו אומרים ככה. בוא נגיד שיש לנו שרשרת נגיד של שלושה.
אוקיי, כמו Dog last או מה שאתם רוצים ויש לנו לצורך העניין רק שלושה פרט אפשרי רק בשביל פשטות ההצגה כן AB וC.
אוקיי, אז בעצם אתם יכולים לתאר כל אחד מהשמות.
התגיות של. זה dog ו Let's בתור מסלול שמתחיל מהשכבה השמאלית ביותר שזה תמיד יהיה start ומסתיים בשכבה השלישית.
נגיד ואם יש לנו stop אז אולי עוד שכבה אחרי זה כן בשכבה הרביעית אז אתם יכולים פשוט לתאר את זה כמסלול.
אם זה AAA אז זה פשוט המסלול העליון ABA אז זה כזה מסלול וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, עכשיו אתם גם יכולים להתאים בעצם לחשב במושגי הגרף הזה את ההסתברות של המסלול.
כי אם עכשיו אנחנו מגדירים את המשקל של כל צלע בתור מכפלה של הקול, זה שם Built שמייצג מייצג את הצלע הזאת, כמו למשל במקרה הקל נכון.
כמו למשל במקרה כאן זה יהיה start לa.
כן, זאת אומרת, יש לנו פה בלטי, אז זה במקרה. כאן זה ALA.
אז פה משהו פה בלתי הזה. במקרה כאן זה זה c a כאילו a.
סליחה אז כן, אז ההסתברות הפעם זה השם הזאת.
אוקיי, ומכפילים את זה בגורם שורה Mission פה ובילתי תחת הנחה שבאמת אנחנו עוברים לתגית או אנחנו בוחרים בתגית שנמצאת בסוף הצלע אז.
נגיד אם החלטנו שווי אחד אי, אז אנחנו צריכים להכפיל בייבי של פר ובלתי איקס אחד.
בהינתן AA החלטנו שX 2 זה X שתיים.
בהינתן A החלטנו שהצטיינו C אז זה x 2 בהינתן C וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז על כל צלע אנחנו יכולים לכתוב את התוצאה שמקובלת, מי שמתאים לה ואת מי שמקבל את מי שמתאים לה.
ואז אם אנחנו נרצה לדעת מה ההסתברות של נגיד AA, מה שנצטרך לעשות זה להכפיל את משקלי הצלעות שאנחנו עוברים בהם וזה בדיוק יצא.
כן, מכפלת הציון זה ישמש AB בהינתן Start A בהינתן AB a כפול מחברת האם ישנו איקס אחד בהינתן 2 בהינתן הקשר שבין התנאים וכנל לגבי כל מסלול אפשרי.
כן ערכיות ABC זה בעצם המאמץ.
כן בדיוק. כן, זה רק לצורך ההדגמה הגרפית.
אוקיי, אז מעולה. אז מה זה עזר לנו? אבל כל הסיפור הזה. אז עכשיו בעצם אנחנו אומרים באופן שקול הצגנו את הבעיה כבעיה של מציאת מסלול כבד ביותר.
נכון, כשהמשקל או כן הכובד של מסלול מוגדר כן.
כמה. כמעט מכפלה.
נכון, מכפלה של מכפלה של המשקלים שהצליחו.
כן. יפה?
לא? איך זה עזר לך? כי בעיות בגרפים אנחנו מכירים סך הכל.
מכל מיני קורסים בשנה א ו ב. נכון, אנחנו רוצים למצוא את המסלול הכבד ביותר שנה אחת שמתחיל.
יש לנו מין גרף שכבות כזה נכון, כמו גרף דו צדדי, רק הרבה כאלה.
מיושרים גרפים שכבות. ואנחנו רוצים להתחיל מהצד השמאלי ביותר ולמצוא מסלול עד נגיד אם יש סטופ בסוף אז כן, אז בין סטארט לסופו.
אם אין סטופ אז לאחד הקטגוריות שמסיימות.
כן. אחד את הקודקודים שנמצא בשכבה האחרונה ואנחנו רוצים למצוא את המסלול הכבד ביותר מבין כל המסלולים האלה.
איך עושים את זה? תכנון דינמי? כן. איך?
איך זה עובד יותר טוב לצורך העניין?
אבל עכשיו אנחנו. מדובר בסיפור אחר להסתבכויות בין קבוצות האינטרס של הקבוצה.
כן, אז צריך לשים לב שזאת בעיה אחרת.
מאמן. בגלל שבמקרה שלנו מה שאנחנו מנסים לפתור זה בעצם בעיית העסק.
בין אם אנחנו אומרים, מה שאנחנו לא יודעים זה את הפרמטרים של המודל ויש לנו training data ואנחנו מנסים למצוא נכון.
כאן אנחנו אומרים אנחנו יודעים את הפרמטרים של המודל שזה condition במי פה bites.
יש שם את איקס ואנחנו מנסים למצוא את הוויסות. אוקיי. יפה.
אז איך עושים את זה? זוכרים תכנון דינמי? נניח שכן ערך.
אוקיי, מי שלא זוכר כדאי להיזכר. בגדול אנחנו רוצים לפרק את הבעיה לתתי בעיות נכון?
ואז אותה לפרק לתתי בעיות וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. ואנחנו צריכים לעשות את זה באופן שפתרון אופטימלי לבעיה גדולה מורכב מפתרון אופטימלי לתת הבעיה.
ועוד משהו שאנחנו יודעים לחשב בקלות באיזושהי דרך.
אוקיי, אז מה נעשה כאן? אנחנו אומרים בסדר, אם יש לנו גרף עם הרבה שכבות ואולי גם הרבה קודקודים בכל שכבה, אז אוקיי, אנחנו נעבור על כל המסלולים.
זה קצת מוגזם, אבל למצוא את המסלול הכבד ביותר נגיד לשכבה הראשונה זה נראה כן בידינו.
נכון? זה כן משהו שאנחנו יודעים לעשות. מהו המסלול הכבד ביותר לקודקוד בשכבה הראשונה?
בסדר. את הצלע הכבדה ביותר, נכון? אז אין כל כך הרבה כמספר התגיות זה בסדר?
אוקיי, אז יפה, אז להתחיל מסלול? אנחנו יודעים את המסלול הכבד ביותר, לא הבעיה.
הבעיה הייתה נגמרת כאן ועכשיו. אם אנחנו יודעים מה הפתרון האופטימלי עבור איזה שהוא אין, בוא נגיד שאפילו עברו הרבה שכבות עד שהגענו לכאן,
ואנחנו יודעים מה הפתרון האופטימלי עבור קודקוד, עבור מסוים שמגיעים עד כאן, עבור מסוים שמגיעים עד כאן והבונוסים שמגיעים עד כאן.
אז איך אנחנו מוצאים את הפתרון האופטימלי עבור מסלולים שמגיעים עד כאן?
גם כן. בדיוק אז כבר בעצם ביצענו הרבה מאד חישובים.
נכון? כי אנחנו שמים לב שהמסלול הכבד ביותר שמגיע עד כאן חייב להיות מורכב ממסלול כבד ביותר
שמגיע לכאן או למסלול כבד ביותר שמגיע לכאן או לשם כבד ביותר שמגיע מכאן לכאן.
נכון, כי אם הוא תת אופטימלי עבור הקודקוד שדרכו הוא עובר, אז מחליף אותו במשהו יותר טוב ונקבל גלובלית.
אז בסדר, זה ברור. אז אנחנו רואים אחלה, אבל אנחנו כבר יודעים מה הכי טוב לכאן.
אז אם מה שהכי טוב לכאן זה כאן, נדידת עבורו זה ואחרי זה הצלע הזאת מעולה.
ניקח את הטוב ביותר, נכפיל בצלע הזאת, קיבלו כאן מדידת מספר אחד כטוב ביותר.
עד כאן בהיקפו. הצלע הזאת, סקנדינבית מספר שתיים טוב ביותר.
עד כאן כפול הצלע שלא כתובה כאן הזאת זה קאדילק מספר 3, אחד מהם הוא המקסימלי.
ניקח את המקסימום ביניהם. זה הטוב ביותר עבור A וככה נמשיך ונעדכן לכל אחד מהקודקוד.
נבנה את השכבה אחרי שכבה ועד שנגיע לשכבה האחרונה ונקבל את מה שאנחנו רוצים.
אז איך זה נראה פורמלית? כן. אז הנה כן, הגרף יותר מלא בלי כל ההסתברויות.
אז אנחנו כן, איכשהו צריכים כל פעם לחשב את הכבד ביותר עד קודקוד מסוים ולהרחיב אותו לשכבה הבאה.
קוראים לגרף הזה גם צ'רלס הרבה פעמים כן, אז אולי אתם גם תראו את השם הזה?
יכול להיות שתתקלו בו? לא יודע למה קוראים לו ככה, אבל בסדר.
כן, ואנחנו רוצים לעשות דינמיקות בנושא הזה. מה שעכשיו הסברתי לך יפה.
אז האלגוריתם קרוי על שם בחור בשם פיטר.
שפיתח אותו. ואיך בעצם עובד על זה?
פשוט אלגוריתם תכנון דינאמי. כן כן, זה פשוט ההנחות של הבעיה.
ההגדרה של הבעיה עבור מודל עבור מודל Try גרם.
אז מה אנחנו עושים? נגיד שאין הוא אורך המשפט.
כן, אורך השרשרת שאנחנו רוצים למצוא עבורה תגיות.
אנחנו מסתכלים ומגדירים בתור Ask את אוסף התגיות האפשרי עבור התוכן הקיים.
נגיד למשל באפס ומינוס אחד זה יהיה רק סטארט בעשרים פלוס אחד.
אולי זה יהיה רק Stop באמצע. זה כנראה יהיה כולם, אולי לא מאיזשהי סיבה יש לנו.
אנחנו רוצים לצמצם. יפה אז זה S האפשרויות בכל שלב, ואנחנו מגדירים בעצם את החישוב החלקי באורך,
כי כן את החישוב החלקי עד השלב הכי עבור היפותזה על התגיות וואי אחד הוויקי עבור השמה אפשרית.
לכן התגיות הראשונות זה פשוט הסתברויות המעברים את הנקודה k כפול הסתברויות Mission.
זאת הנקודה כי במילים אחרות זה משקל שמה של איזה תת בעיה או איזה תת מסלול.
כן כן, זה בדיוק זה בעצם המסלול של הרשע, של מסלול נכון, כזה שעובר מאחד עד Y.
קיי. אז זה בדיוק yo? אה כן, זה בדיוק המכפלה.
כן, אם אנחנו משנים פה את סדר המכפלה, זה בדיוק יהיה מכפלת הצלעות של קיי השלבים הראשונים נכון של קיי המהלכים הראשונים.
עכשיו אנחנו יכולים לבנות את עדיין המכפלה הדומיננטי קיבל את הטבלה.
נגדיר את Pink חיובי בתור ההסתברות המקסימלית עבור סדרה של תגיות שמסתיימת בחיובי.
כן, עכשיו אנחנו trigger להזכירכם. אז כל מצב הוא בעצם שתי התגיות האחרונות, לא רק התגית האחרונה.
אז כן, אז אנחנו צריכים להתנות עליו וי. כל המסלולים באורך קיי שמסתיימים בחיובי.
כן, או ככה זה כתוב פורמלית, ועכשיו אנחנו יכולים להגדיר תנאי נסיגה.
אנחנו יכולים להגדיר את השכבה באורך אפס. אפשר להתחיל מתנאי בסיס אפס בסדר.
זה המסלולים הריקים. כן, זה אחד שאפשר להתחיל מאורך אחד ואז פשוט מקסימום על הצלעות.
אותו דבר אפילו לא. מקסימום ממש פשוט.
ההסתברות של אצבעות כן, כי זאתי שמסתיימת בקודקוד מסוים באורך אחד, כלומר יש רק אפשרות אחת ועכשיו מנוסחת הרקורסיה.
מה היא אומרת? בדיוק כמו שאמרנו קודם, ההסתברות שהמסלול או שרת תת מסלול הטוב ביותר עבור או עבור רישא K כן אחד עד קיי שמסתיים בתגיות יופי מהו אז?
המסלול הזה מורכב מתת מסלול אופטימלי, מסלול אופטימלי שאם הקודם נגמר ביובש V, אז תת מסלול באורך אחד פחות נגמר ביום.
נכון ובעוד משהו קודקודים אנחנו לא יודעים מה זה המשהו הזה.
אז בוא נקרא לזה דאבליו כרגע כן.
אז אנחנו הוא מורכב, מפיקים מינוס אחד דאבליו ויהיו כפול משקל הצלע שאנחנו נצטרך לעבור בה כדי לעבור מהמצב דאבליו למצב חיובי.
אוקיי, שזה בדיוק ובהינתן דבליו בהינתן e של איקס k, בהינתן V בסדר, אז זה בדיוק נוסחת הנסיגה שראינו קודם גרפית,
וזה מאפשר לנו לחשב בעצם את הטבלה על ידי חישוב דינמי על ידי קאשינג.
שלח פשוט שאלות. כן?
כן, כי כי בעצם אוקיי, מה?
איך נראה הגרף? אז אולי אתה עוצר שנייה חתיכה קטנה ממנו כדי להבין.
אז בעצם מה אנחנו אומרים? איך זה נראה בטריק טראמפ?
נכון, אנחנו אומרים המתחיל בסטארט Start.
נכון, אחרי זה בשכבה הראשונה יש start a נגיד ABC או נכון אז start a start b start c.
נכון והשכבות הבאות יהיו מורכבות מ כן, כל הקומבינציות נכון.
הרווחים וכן הלאה כל הדברים.
אז אוקיי, עכשיו אנחנו אומרים ככה אנחנו אומרים מסלול.
הטוב ביותר שנגיד מגיע ל A בשכבה הקיימת.
כן, ממה הוא מורכב? אני צריך להסתכל על מסלולים אופטימליים.
על השכבה כי פחות אחד נכון. עכשיו אם שני האחרונים שלי, כלומר k מינוס אחד הם a.
וואי וואי מינוס אחד הוא a אז זה אומר שבטוח אני צריך להסתכל כאן רק על תת אוסף של קודקודים נכון?
איזה? כן שמסתיימות ב a כן, בהנחה שזה הראשון אז זה בעצם זה?
זה. כן, זה זה וזה.
נכון שזה בעצם למקסם עליהם?
זה אותו דבר כמו למקסם על כל האפשרויות לוואי כי מינוס שתיים.
כן פסיק A פסיק you בעצם שאותו קיבלתי מכאן.
בסדר, עוד פעם נחזור על זה? אוקיי, אני זה אם אני בוחר את הקודקוד הזה.
מה זה אומר? למה התחייבתי? שוואי קיי שווה ל.
ושווי K מינוס אחד שווה ל. לי לא, לא, כי כי אני מסיים פה ב A אם הייתי מסיים ב.
סליחה אם הייתי מסיים ב AB אז.
אז אז מינוס אחד היה B. כן.
עכשיו אני אומר אם אני מסיים בA זה אומר שהיה הקודקוד שהגעתי ממנו.
חייב להיות משהו A. יפה.
מה זה המשהו הזה? וואי כן מינוס שתיים.
בסדר. אוקיי.
ברור שנשארת לגבי זה. יפה.
אז זאת נוסחת הנסיגה ואני יכול לעדכן כן את הטבלה.
כל פעם מתחיל מיקי שווה אחד הבסיס או שווה אפס ולוקח בכל פעם את המקסימום לפי נוסחת הרקורסיה ובסוף מחזיר את הפאי שיש בו את הערך הכי גבוה מהשכבה n נכון,
את המקסימום על פני כל הקומבינציות של שתי הקטגוריות האחרונות.
יו מביא על פי אן. כן כפול סטופ של חיובי, כי יכול להיות שחלק מהתגליות יותר סבירות.
הקטגוריות של סוף השרשרת נכון. וכמובן אני צריך Back פה אינטרס.
נכון, אם אני רוצה לדעת גם מה זה סדרת הY ולא רק מה ההסתברות של סדרת הY, כלומר את האב מקס ולא רק את מקס.
זה סטנדרטי לחלוטין ודינאמי גם נכון. אני צריך לדעת איפה התקבל המקסימום,
כלומר באיזה דאבליו התקבל המקסימום בכל שלב ואז אני יכול אחורה נכון למצוא את המקסימום בשכבה האחרונה וממנו ללכת אחורה ולמצוא את כל הווים,
לפחות את אחד מהסדרות שמקדמות את ההסתברות של Y ואיקס.
כן, כשאתה יודע על ידי back point זה מוכר, אני מניח נכון חומר כזה של אלגוריתמים.
בסדר. מה לגבי זמן הריצה? אז בוא נסתכל.
בוא נסתכל. היינו צריכים למלא את הטבלה פאי נכון?
מה הגודל שלה? בוא נראה יש לה הארגומנט ראשון שמקבל ערכים.
או שלם ערכים נכון, אולי הוספנו אחד הורדנו אחד משהו כזה.
וארגון שני ושלישי שמקבלים אפס כן מקבלים.
כן, בדיוק כאילו כמספר התביעות האפשריות.
אז זה אומר שגודל הטבלה היא או של מספר התגיות בריבוע כפול אורך המשפט?
וכמה לוקח להן? מה? מה הסיבוכיות של לחשב כל תא בטבלה מהקודמים לו?
אז כן, בדיוק אז גם כמספר התגיות אז יש לנו אין.
אס בריבוע תאים. כל אחד מהם זה הוא של אס.
אנחנו מקבלים סדר גודל של S בשלישית כפול.
אגב, אם זה היה מודל בייט גם כן נגיד אם היה לנו במקרה כזה אז מה היה סיבוכיות זמן הריצה?
מה היינו צריכים להחזיק בעצם? מה גודל הטבלה? אבל.
לא התכוונתי דווקא אחד פחות. כאילו דרגה אחת פחות.
כן, אז הטבלה בעצם הייתה צריכה להחזיק.
מה אין אס נכון? כאילו לכל קודקוד כל קודקוד.
זה היה פשוט הקטגוריה Wii עבור כל האפשרויות לקטגורית ועבור כל i,
אז אין s וכדי לחשב כל אחד מהם שוב היינו צריכים למקסם על פני סדר גודל של מספר התגיות ערכים אז הם מקבלים אס בריבוע.
אם היינו עולים למודל מסדר אחד יותר גבוה, כלומר ל for גם מודל, אז.
היינו עולים בחזקה, נכון? וזה עונה מה שמך?
סליחה אורית דורי אה נורית סליחה, אז כמו שנורית ציינה היינו עולים לאנס ברביעית וכן הלאה.
כן, היינו מגדילים את המודל. זה היה עכשיו מה שחשוב לצרכינו זה מכיוון שבדרך כלל אנחנו מניחים שמספר התגיות הוא איזשהו משהו קבוע,
ממד שבו כמובן תלוי במקרה, אבל בדרך כלל זה כמה עשרות או כן משהו כזה של תגיות ברוב המקרים.
אז אצבע שלישית זה משהו שאפשר להתמודד איתו.
אפילו אס ברביעית אין. התלות שלו היא רק לינארית, שזה מצוין, כמובן בגלל שזה יכול להיות מאוד ארוך.
אם יש לנו סדרות מאוד ארוכות של שאנחנו רוצים לתייק.
יפה, אז בגדול זה לא סליחה, קפץ לי משהו באמצע, אז זה מסיים בעצם את הנקודה של ויתר של האינטרנט ומשאיר לנו שאלה אחת אחרונה לגבי H3 מהימים שהיא.
למידה בדיוק. אז למידה? זה בעצם מה שאנחנו עושים ביחד?
אז ככה, בגדול גם כאן אנחנו נרצה להשתמש במקסימום להיות Stimulation.
בדרך כלל מה שיוצא כשאתם הולכים ובאמת חושבים איזה ערכים לפרמטרים ומקסימים את ההסתברות.
אתם מגלים שגם כאן, משיקולים מאוד דומים, זה יוצא בעצם ספירות.
כלומר לשערך את זה שם פה. Bullet is בהינתן training data, כלומר בהינתן סדרות מתויגות זה פשוט לספור כמה פעמים הופיע ווי שלוש כהמשך של ווי אחד ווי,
שתיים מתוך סך כל הפעמים שהופיע וואי אחד בוואי שתיים.
וכנל לגבי מי שמוביל את איז ההסתברות שהופיע שהופיע איקס אחד כתב שש, כלומר שהופיע מילה איקס אחד עם התיוג Y אחד מתוך סך כל המקרים שבהם מופיע Y אחד.
וכרגיל בשיעורים ממין אלו יש לנו בעיות של ספר הסתיים ואנחנו חייבים לעשות כל מיני החלקות לפעמים.
אז בגדול Christian Bulletin זה החלקות מאוד דומות לחלקות שראינו בהן גם.
מצד אחד יש לנו הרבה פחות קטגוריות, כן או הרבה פחות מחלקות, כי באין גרם models במקום language models.
מה היה מספר הערכים האפשריים במודל מרכיבי? הסברתי לך במעקב language models.
נכון, זה המודל. מה קובי שאיזה ערכים יכול לקבל כל XI?
בעצם כל בדיוק כל בעצם כל מילה.
סדר גודל של אוצר המילים שהוא עצום. בדרך כלל לפחות עשרות אלפים, לפעמים מאות אלפים של של תכנים שונים.
מצד שני היה לנו הרבה דאטה כי לא צריך דאטה מתויג כאן במקרה.
כאן יש לנו משמעותית פחות קטגוריות נכון מאשר מספר המילים.
בדרך כלל, כאמור, מדובר על כמה עשרות. להבדיל מכמה מאות אלפים, אבל יש לנו בדרך כלל הרבה פחות דאטה.
אז יש קצת שוני, אבל סך הכל דברים דומים מבחינת הדבר השני.
Mission זאת ממש בעיה. זאת ממש בעיה כי תשימו לב מה קורה כאן, כמה סך הכל mission mission.
אז יש לנו עבור מודל Home. כמה פרמטרים יש לנו שערך?
בדיוק כמות המילים כפול כמות הלייבלים. כלומר זה טוב שכמות הלייבלים הם אולי כמה עשרות, אבל כאמור מספר המילים הוא אולי כמה מאות אלפים.
כלומר אנחנו. יש לנו די הרבה פרמטרים לשערך.
כן מיליונים, אבל מצד שני אנחנו חייבים לעשות את זה על סמך יומן.
אין הטיית Data. כן, כמה כבר כאלה יש לנו?
בדרך כלל לא המון. במקרה הטוב ביותר שניתן לדמיין זה כמה מיליונים בסך הכל.
כן, הרבה פעמים פחות, ואפילו אם כמה מיליונים זה עדיין בסדר גודל של מספר הפרמטרים, כנראה אפילו פחות מזה.
אולי סדר גודל פחות. אז אנחנו חייבים להחליק, אז אנחנו חייבים להחליק.
ובמקרה כאן אין לנו את האפשרות של Back of Models כמו באנג Models.
מה שדיברנו על זה כי פשוט אין כאן שום בקו, זה פשוט מילה.
בהינתן קטגוריה האסוציאציה בין מילה לקטגוריה, אז מה אפשר לעשות?
אז שיטה אחת להתמודד עם זה ואנחנו נראה כל מיני שיטות בקורס להתמודד עם זה.
אבל נתחיל מהבסיס שאם מסתבר שיטה לא כל כך גרועה בהרבה מקרים כן, למרות שהיא בסיסית.
אם אתם מחפשים פתרון קוויקי and Dirty, זה יכול הרבה פעמים להיות פתרון לא רע.
זה בעצם מה שנקרא סוד Words.
כן, להבדיל מיסודו Count שהיה לנו בפעם שעברה.
כן ספירות מדומות. כאן יש לנו מילים מדומות פסאודו וואטס שבעצם זה שם מפוצץ לרעיון.
פשוט רעיון אומר. אנחנו רוצים לחלק את המילים, את כל המילים, כלומר גם את אלה שבטי Secret.
כן, וגם את אלה שבתאי נקסט. אנחנו רוצים לחלק אותם לקטגוריות שיש לנו יסוד להאמין ש ההתפלגות של התגיות באותה קטגוריה כן.
עבור מילים ששייכות לאותה קטגוריה היא בערך דומה. אוקיי.
עכשיו מה אנחנו הולכים? אז איזה קטגוריות וסליחה זה קריטריון אחד זה הקריטריון השני הוא שאנחנו גם יכולים בהינתן שאנחנו רואים איך מילה כתובה,
אנחנו גם יכולים לדעת לאיזו קטגוריה לסווג אותה. אז למשל אולי תו digest נאמבר, אז יכול להיות כזה דבר כן חד מספרים זה צרה.
אם תחשבו על זה נכון, כי איכשהו יש מספר עצום שלהם, אפילו אם אנחנו מניחים שהוא איכשהו חסום בטקסטים סבירים, אבל יש מספר אדיר שלהם.
אבל מה שעומד כן. מה שככה מאפשר לנו לומר זהו זה שבגדול הם מכולם.
ההתפלגות שלהם היא התפלגות די כאילו מספרים שונים מתפלגים בצורה די דומה.
אכזבה.
יהיה לנו קטגוריה לתותי hit Numbers לפועל Digital numbers לקנטינה אין אין אלפאנו מריק לקנטינה אין death container digest and סלש זה באמת רשימה אמיתית,
כי הם חלק ממנה, כי הם מספרים. אחרים מספרים עם נקודות מספרים, מפסיקים דברים שנראים כמו תאריך.
כן, אפשר לכתוב רגולרי Expression כזה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, עכשיו ברור שהדברים האלה כבר מסייעים הרבה פעמים.
ואנחנו אומרים טוב, אם אין לנו משהו, איזשהו פתרון נורא נחמד כמו נראה כמו תאריך או נראה כמו קינסי או נראה כמו כאלה דברים.
לכל הפחות אנחנו יכולים להגיד דברים כמו האם זה אול Capture, שזה אולי קבוצה קצת פחות הטרוגנית, קצת פחות הומוגנית.
סליחה מבחינת הקטגוריות, אבל עדיין כן, כי אולי מישהו נכון אול cap סטרים לפעמים מישהו מתעצבן?
נכון? אז כותבים כתבו על כפס או כל מיני דברים כאלה, אבל זה גם הרבה פעמים זיעה קונים או דברים כאלה.
אז אולי כן אפשר ללמוד מזה משהו? אם זה מילה ראשונה במשפט, זאת אומרת בגדול יש לנו מין היררכיה כזאת, מין איזשהו סדר על הקטגוריות שאנחנו אומרים.
יש קטגוריות מסוימות שנגיע אליהם רק אם לא נפלתי בקטגוריות היותר ספציפיות, כמו נראה כמו תאריך, נראה כמו זה וכן הלאה.
וזה כבר מוריד את הספר City בצורה ניכרת. אוקיי, האם זה בפני עצמו מספיק?
לא. אנחנו נלמד על שיטות יותר טובות מזה, אבל זאת כבר מסתבר.
התחלה שנותנת לנו לא מעט. כן, אתם תופתעו אולי מכמה מהמילים הנדירות שאתם נתקלים בהם.
הקורפוסים הם בעצם כל מיני דברים כאלה, עם נקודה באמצע או עם פסיק באמצע או גם האמת.
טעויות גרם טעויות כתיב ומי שזה עדיין לא דיברנו עליהם, אבל אפשר גם אותם לנסות לתקן.
כן, איכשהו עם אספלט שקר.
שוב, זה הכל יוריס תקוות, אבל זה דברים שאיכשהו עוזרים להתמודד עם הספר City.
בסדר, ואז מה שברגע שיש לנו את האוסף הזה של קטגוריות,
מה שאנחנו יכולים לעשות זה פשוט להמיר את המילים כן להמיר בעצם את המילים Training Data שלנו בקטגוריות האלה.
כן, ובעצם ללמוד לגבי כל אחת מהקטגוריות. כן, לגבי כל אחת מהפסד אוואנס.
מה ההתפלגות שלה על? על התגיות השונות או בהינתן כל תגית, מה ההתפלגות שלה על אוצר מילים שכולל גם את הסוד.
אבל בדרך כלל אנחנו לא נרצה להחליף את כל המילים בת שהיא נמצאת לצד של סודה Words, כי פשוט היא מילה.
היא מספיק נפוצה. כנראה שנעדיף להשאיר אותה נכון היא סך הכל אינדיקציה יותר טובה, ולכן השיטה המקובלת היא לשים איזשהו פיתרון.
סעיף ראשון אוקיי, אז נגיד במקרה כאן אולי profit הוא נדיר יחסית גדולה,
אז הוא הפך להיות Ford, אבל סורג ועץ הם לא נדירות אז הם נשארו רגילות ובואינג היא כן.
אז היא הפכה היא נתקעת, כלומר של capital letter.
אוקיי. שאלות לגבי זה.
אבל אין לך את זה. אם נגיד עכשיו רוצה להראות שיש לך איזה סם כלשהו שניתן לבצע, אתה מכיר את המנה המקורית, אפילו שהוא חסר טעם.
אוקי, אז מה? אז לפחות בטכניקה הסטנדרטית של Words.
זה ממש כללים דטרמיניסטי.
כלומר זה לא בעיית דיקציה לדעת בהינתן איך שמילה כתובה, מה סוד הוורד שלה, אלא פשוט מין אוסף של הרגל כזה, או אולי היררכיה ביניהם.
יכול להיות שזאת טעות במובן הזה שהוא קיבץ יחד מילים שאין שום קשר בין ההתפלגויות ואז מה שאתה תקבל זה פשוט איזושהי שגיאה שנובעת מזה.
כן כן. זה היה יכול להפוך את זה. ניתן היה להשיג את היעדים האלה כאילו לא היה ניצול, נכון?
הייתה ביקורת? כמובן שלא כל כך נכון.
נכון? ואנחנו באמת נלמד. כנראה בשיעור הבא כבר או זה שאחריו.
נלמד על מה שנקרא Distribution סמנטיקה או ההתפתחותית על איך אפשר לייצג משמעויות של
מילים או או איזשהו לפחות אספקט מסוים של שימוש במילים על ידי התפוצה שלהם בקורפוס.
וברגע שנדבר על זה גם נוכל, נוכל להפעיל כלים מתוחכמים יותר להתמודד עם.
עם מילים נדירות. אם יש לך אפילו מודל של אומנות בצורה טובה אפילו אכפת.
החלוקה עוסקת בסמנטיקה של היישוב.
הוא כולל 20 קטגוריות לספרות אחת. כמה עם כל הנושא?
טוב. כן. וכל הדו בעצם כל חלוקה, לא משנה לי מה המוטיבציה של החלוקה,
כל עוד יש לי דרך מהימנה להמיר מילים בקטגוריה שלהם, כל עוד הקטגוריות להחליף מילה לקטגוריה שמילה.
לא מאבד המון אינפורמציה לגבי ה. דהיינו הקטגוריות שלי הם יחסית הומוגניות ולא מקפצות יחד ולא מקפצות יחד דברים שהם לא קשורים.
תחת שתי ההנחות האלה אני יכול בעצם הרבה פעמים.
לא נורא משנה לי אם זה קטגוריה סמנטית או קטגוריה מסוג א או ב או סוג ג.
כן, או אוטו גרפית או כל דבר אחר. בסדר.
אז אם לסכם את הדיון שלנו בעידן מורכב מאוד, אז זו home.
בגדול, home הם פתרון פשוט יחסית.
כן, ומאוד נפוץ בהרבה מאוד הקשרים, גם הרבה מעבר ל NLP עבור בעיה של סיקוונס פרודקשן.
כן, בעיה שאנחנו רוצים לחזות בעצם פרויקט שיעבור סדרה של סדרה של אימפוטנטים, כך שיש איזשהו תלות ביניהם.
תלות לוקאלית זה קל מאוד לאמן אותו בגדול, זה לספור ולהחליק, ולמרות שאין פרנס על פניו אולי נראה קצת מאיים, רחב, אקספוננציאלי וכדומה.
יש אלגוריתם יעיל לינארי באורך באורך השרשרת שנקרא פיטר בי שמסוגל לעשות Influence.
הבעיות העיקריות איתו זה שיש לו הנחות יכולות מאוד חזקות, בייחוד ההנחה השנייה שדיברנו עליה כן שהמילים לא משפיעות אחת על השני.
השניה בהינתן קטגוריה ות כמו הרבה פעמים הזכרתי את זה בקצרה בשיעור הקודם, כמו הרבה פעמים במקרה של מודלים כן, נרטיבים.
היכולת שלנו להשתמש בפיצ'רים מורכבים היא מוגבלת.
כן, בעצם בפיצ'רים שיש ביניהם מבני תלויות מורכבים יש בעיה להשתמש בהם,
והעובדה שבדרך כלל משתמשים ביט שמים בלי מבני פיצ'רים מסובכים, או אפילו כמו שעשינו כאן, שבעצם סך הכל היה לנו מולטי נומי.
נכון ההסתברות. ההסתברות של מילה בהינתן קטגוריה הייתה מולטי נועם או אולי מולטי נעמי באיזושהי החלקה לצוד Words.
אבל סך הכל לא היה לנו שם פיצ'רים מתוחכמים במיוחד.
או כן או שיש ביניהם כן, שיש ביניהם איזה שהם מבנה תלויות מורכב ולבעיה הזאת, או בעצם לשתי הבעיות האלה אנחנו נידרש עכשיו,
כשבעצם נתחיל לדבר על מודלים, דיסקים, נתיבים לסיכון, מודלינג Minimum ואחרי זה create.
אז אני תוהה. אני כבר רואה שעוד כמה דקות הפסקה אולי אפשר.
באמת שפשוט נחזור כמה דקות קודם מההפסקה ואז כבר נעשה את זה ברצף.
בסדר, אז בוא נחזור, נגיד בחמישה לשתיים ואז נעשה שיעור על דיסקונט.
תפסיק לצפות. של.
עדיין לא. בעצם כן, מתברר שכן.
זאת שאלה טובה. בגלל שבעצם אנחנו מתחתנים עשרה לקוחות אז בעצם שוקלים את הכל ביחד.
נכון? זאת אומרת אתה אומר זה לא שאתה קודם מחליט על זמן הלידה של הראשון ואז זה בצד השני, אלא אתה בעצם אומר יש לי אני יש.
לי יש את score function שהוא נותן score לכל מרחב אקספוננציאלי.
ובתוך המרחב הזה אני נמצאת הבוקר. ומסתבר שלמרות שאנחנו צריכים לצאת בבוקר, זה מפני שלא יכול לצאת מהבית את האוכל.
אז בעצם התחושה היא לצאת פחות. אין כאן עניין שאתה קודם מחזיר את זה ואז חוזרת, מבינה ואומרת בסוף זה מה שהכי כבר עשו אחרי הדבר ואתה מתחיל לחזור אחורה.
אבל אני שואל, הייתי צריך לבחור בדבר הזה.
אז זה בעצם הרבה זמן. כן, אני אולי אחזור על זה עכשיו.
נתחיל בזה שבאמת מלחיץ בבית הספר. אז בעצם ההנחה היא בעצם כן.
ברגע שאני מתמודד אז אין כל משמעות.
זה גם כדור הארץ וגם כל מה שהיה באותו מבנה.
בעצם יצרנו את המשפט הוא יקבל את זה כאילו אם אנחנו עכשיו.
כן, אני מעריצה את הרצון שלך. כן, זאת אומרת, אני חושבת על זה כמודל שאמור לייצר טוב מאוד, אז ברור שכן.
זה נכון שאת אומרת ובעצם, אבל אפשר גם לחשוב על זה לכיוון ההפוך.
אם היום בנקודה של האינטרנט ובעצם זה בעצם.
מה שזה יגרום, מה שזה יגרום זה שזה.
פשוט קצת יותר מורכב לעשות את זה אפילו כאן.
שמעתי על זה מהצד של הכנסת, אבל בואי נגיד שעד עכשיו.
אז בואי נגיד שאת עכשיו רוצה לחזות את הקטגוריה של.
הטקס בוקר של איזשהו עולם המשפט. ואת יודעת.
נגיד אפילו את הקטגוריות של אתמול. אפילו בוא נניח את כולם.
כן, אני חושבת שזה עדיין מצב החלומות, אבל את יודעת אמילי.
אוקיי. אז בעצם במקרה?
אז תחת ההנחה הזאת בעצם. את לא מאבדת שני חומציות.
את לא מאבדת שום אינפורמציה בגלל הדטרמיניזם, למרות שבהחלט יכולה להיות אינפורמציה.
כן, אולי פשוט להסתכל בצורה טובה יותר מתוחכמת. למשל, בוא נגיד שיש לך מזל שיש לך נגיד די, צנצנת יפה.
אני לא כזה, כמו כי Grant כזה שמקבל שני נושאים על השפתיים.
אבל את מצפה שיהיה לך שברי מאמץ או שניים פחות של טיילור כאילו הוא או משהו כזה.
זאת אומרת, זה כבר אומר לך מה שצריכים להיות לך בהמשך המשפט כדורי שינה.
אבל. אבל בהנחה שלא קלטת את הידע הזה בתוך הקטגוריה של המידע, אז בעצם בלי פרופורציה ולא יודעת מה לעשות.
נכון. אז אני יכול להשאיר בעצם את הנושא על האינטרס הציבורי.
אז איך אפשר? תחשוב על אולי איזו שהיא דוגמה עוד יותר מתוחכמת.
זה היה הבעייתיות שעלולה לדמיין את הפרדוקס.
אני מתכוון להניח שבפרס שיש כבר מפרסמים שיש, יש כבר את כל האינפורמציה שאני צריך מהמילים האחרות במשפט,
ואני לא צריך לדעת מה זה המילה הזאת בשביל לתאר תסריט שמתאים יותר להצפנת המילים, לא בשיטות של שלום.
אני יודע האמת. וזה לא נראה כאילו אפשר שלא.
אתה צודק שאפשר להשאיר את הקטגוריות, אבל כנראה שזה כנראה שלא באמת תצליחי למצוא איך לקודד בתוך הקטגוריות את כל החוקיות שאפשר.
כן, אז לא יודע מה נעשה עכשיו. עוד דוגמאות.
אז נגיד למשל, הנה עוד דוגמה אחרת כן, מאנגלית, נכון?
אז יש את הסעיף באנגלית שיכולים להופיע וזה חוקי לחלוטין, אבל לא יכולים להופיע בפני עצמם,
כמו למשל בתור גזלן, אבל לא הגיע לאיזו עבודה כי זה פרי, אבל לא תמיד.
זו סתם דוגמה אחרת שיצא לי מראש וכאלה.
ואז זה שאת יודעת שזה בעצם זה שאת יודעת שמשהו את שכתב לא נותן לך את הכל.
כל נגיד למשל, אם את יודעת שיש את המילה wake אז את יודעת שכנראה באיטליה אפרטהייד קובנית נכון?
למרות שזה אסור high כאילו זה ממש. נכון.
אז שוב, גם את זה אני יכולה לקנות את החפצים. לומר לעצמך באיזשהו שלב, כבר תקופה כל כך ארוכה כבר רציתי לכתוב מילה, אז זה ברור, וזה המון.
אבל אז נתקל בבעיה מכיוון אחרת. אני חושב שפה צריכים לתת בכל זאת אם יש המון קטגוריות על כל אחד מחמישה פרמטרים, כן, אז כאילו זה ימשוך אותך.
גם משקיף מוסמך מזכיר שהכל בסדר, אבל בעיקרון הבנתי שהפורמט אתה ראית שזה כאילו זה כולל את צריכת הקלוריות שלי לפורמטים מסוימים.
אני מנסה להבין מה העולם הטיפוסי לראות, למה זה מתחלק אחרת ואיך אני משתמש אחרי דיבורית בלוטות.
את הדברים נשאל בשידור. אחרת.
חבל לך על זה. כך יעשה מי שכועס וזה רע.
אבל אתה רוצה לחזור על זה?
אני מניח שעוד אנשים לא מבינים מה קרה.
אני לא יודע עד כמה תכננת להספיק היום. אני מנסה.
אני לא. בואי נעשה את זה בשמחה.
סליחה, אבל אני אני עכשיו יש לי את זה עליו.
אני רק אוכל ארוחת בוקר. אני לא יודעת מה זה.
למעשה זהו. לא מדובר באיזה.
חלק. ואני אגיד.
זה משהו זה? אישה עצמאית.
היה אחד הראשונים.
כל הזמן. אני רוצה לשמוע את השם שלה.
היא טובה. אני. אני יודע טוב מאחרים.
את האמת אני צריך לסמוך על. בשלב זה לא ברור עדיין מה היה אמור לעשות.
רוצה לדעת אם בן יוסף? איזה משפט.
איפה אני יכולה לקחת אותה?
איזו דוגמה? זה?
לבית המשפט המחוזי. בניגוד למקום.
מה עם תפוחי האדמה? איפה? אני לא יודעת מה אני צריכה להגיד, אבל יש לי כמה שאלות שלא.
ראש המועצה. האזורית שומרון גרשון מסיקה.
גם מנהל שמואל הנגיד סטנלי. פישר.
הבעיה. לא חייבת להיות יוצאת דופן גם.
אני מנסה לפתור. את הפער הזה כמה שעות אחרי שכבר.
סיים את העבודה. 3.
כל אחד יודע איפה זה נמצא. עכשיו הסילבוס.
האישה. כרגע יש עוד כמה שנים טובות שאנחנו עוברים וגם אז לא עושים את זה כל 20 שנה אז עוד יותר טוב.
לא הבנתי מה זה משנה. נשמע שמדובר זה פשוט.
לא את הראש. וזה ממש ממש בקצרה.
אני סובל. הנחת העבודה של גורמי.
יחס זה לא צריך, אבל זה.
לא משנה. אני בדעתי גם.
אני מניח שאתה מציין גם את זה.
ראשית, אני רוצה לומר. הרגשתי כאילו אני בת 23.
פעם אחת. 15.
מה זה בעצם דקסטר? היא אחת משתיים שלוש.
אבל יכול להיות שיש פה קבוצה. תמיד.
האם של. אני לא מסוגלת.
כל שניתן. הקושי האמיתי.
64. אין ספק שהיא לא עשתה מהלכים.
יש מקום טוב, לא?
אפשר להציע? אבל רגע, מה אתם יכולים לעשות?
גם. גם בזמן.
מצבו של הרב עובדיה יוסף. 4.
כוחות הביטחון. מבית הספר למשפטים נמסר בתגובה לא צריך לעניין.
אומרים. המצגת הזאת. המצגת הזאת.
כן, אבל. זהו.
היה. אוקיי.
טוב. אז דבר ראשון שאלה שכן ששמעתי בהפסקה לגבי.
לגבי הפסאודו wellness כן איך זה עובד ומה זה עושה?
אז? אז הרעיון הוא בעצם כזה יש לכם, יש לנו עכשיו אנחנו בטריינינג.
כן, יש לנו איזשהו סט של משפטים מיתולוגיים שעליו אנחנו מתאמנים.
כן, אז יש לנו מין סדרות כאלה של איקס אחד אחד.
אה. ויש לנו אולי הרבה כאלה, כנראה.
ועכשיו אנחנו מנסים לשערך נכון את מי שאין פה, כלומר את ההסתברות של XI בהינתן Y.
כן. אז לדוגמה אנחנו רוצים לשערך מה? לא יודע מה?
מה הסיכוי של. לא יודע.
נגיד כן המילה. סקור.
להיות ב. כן, זה אחד מהדוגמאות.
אז. אז עכשיו למקרים כאלה אנחנו נצטרך להמציא טכניקות קצת יותר מתקדמות כדי לסייע.
אבל בוא נניח שעכשיו אנחנו לא מסתכלים על המילה School.
כן, אלא אנחנו מסתכלים נגיד על המילה אלף 1965.
בסדר, אז כאן בהחלט יכול להיות שאין לנו מופעים של 1965 בינתיים Ever, אבל גם מאוד יכול להיות שבאופן כללי הם היו המון מופעים של 1965, אבל מה?
אולי יש לנו את 1967 ב 1970 ו 1990 ואני לא יודע וכל מיני דברים אחרים בסדר.
אז מה אנחנו בכל זאת יכולים לעשות? כדי לשערך את ההסתברות הזאת נוכל לעשות את הדבר הבא להגיד תראו.
1965 מילה נדירה. נכון, היינו רוצים.
תיאורטית, היינו רוצים לשערך את זה אם היה לנו אינסוף data, נכון?
כן כן, בעצם מספר הפעמים שמופיע ועוד אינסוף, אני מתכוון לומר שמספר.
כמות אדירה של דאטה ובמידה היינו כותבים מספר הפעמים של 1965 אינו פשוט מחשבים את המנה הזאת ומקבלים שערוך טוב רק מראש 1965 כמעט לא הופיע.
כן בפרט הוא לא הופיע גם Ever. אבל אנחנו לא רוצים להציג לו אפס.
באופן כללי זאת אפס, אמרנו אנחנו לא אוהבים כי זה מאפס את הכל.
אז מה אנחנו בכל זאת יכולים לעשות?
אנחנו אומרים טוב, תראו, 1965 היא מילה נדירה, אבל יש לנו עוד הרבה מילים נדירות שגם כולם For Digital Numbers שמתחילים ב 1 9.
סתם אני זורק אוקיי, ועכשיו אנחנו מקבצים את כולם לאיזושהי קטגוריה.
זה שם איזשהו רגל לרצפה, שם אחד תשע.
כן, מספר אפס עד תשע 0.
משהו כזה. כן, זה שלנו, מין מחלקה כזאת, נכון?
אז בסדר Word ועכשיו אנחנו חוזרים לסטרימינג data וכל פעם שמילה היא מספיק נדירה,
אולי מילים הנפוצות אנחנו רוצים לשערך ישירות את ההתפלגות שלנו, כאילו יש פה משהו מיוחד.
אתה יודע, אולי זה שם של להקה, נכון? בטח יש שמות של להקות שנראות כמו ארבעה מספרים.
מה לא? אתה לא כל כך התחכום שלי או שמות של משהו אחר.
כן, אז זה אולי אנחנו אומרים בסדר, עזבו אותם. זה כנראה משהו מיוחד.
זה כל הזמן מופיע, אבל יש עוד מלא מספרים שמופיעים בכל מיני.
כל אחד מופיע פעם אחת, אז כולם עכשיו יהפכו להיות הקטגוריה שנקרא הפסאודו word מספר 17.
כן, ועכשיו אנחנו הולכים בעצם לקחת את כל המקרים שבהם מופיעות אמינות המילים האלה בדאטה.
ואם היה כתוב שם 1965, אנחנו הולכים למחוק את זה ולשים במקומו power 17.
ואם פה היה לנו אלף תשע מאות ואחד אז גם אותו אנחנו נמחק ונחליף בפלדה ולמשבר הזה.
אוקיי, ועכשיו מצבנו השתפר.
לכאורה נכון, כי עכשיו מה שאנחנו צריכים לבדוק זה כמה פעמים הפי דבליו 17 זה הופיע עם כל אחת מהקטגוריות,
רק שעכשיו במקום Instant אחד של התוכן יש לנו אולי.
יש לנו, אולי לא יודע מה 30 מצטרפים של התוכן הזה, ואנחנו שמים לב שהתוכן הזה בכל ה 30 פריימים האלה לא מופיע בכלל כבר כן, הוא מופיע רק פעם אחת.
אוקיי, אז אולי עדיין אנחנו צריכים מן החלקה כזאת של פלוס delta Smoking או משהו כזה?
כי ממש אפס אנחנו לא אוהבים, אבל אנחנו כבר במצב הרבה יותר טוב.
כן, כי כי קודם לא ידענו כלום. עכשיו אנחנו יודעים שזה כנראה קטגוריה.
ווטאבר. קטגוריה נעה נו מה שלא יהיה עוד.
מה שלא יהיה שמציינים במספרים של שנים וכל שאר המחלקות מקבלות הסתברות די זניחה.
בסדר. אוקיי.
יפה. אז בואו עכשיו נדבר על מדעי מסכים.
נתתי אז כזכור את שמה.
סך הכל נתנו לנו פתרון מעניין לבעיה של איך אנחנו בעצם עושים מה שנקרא structure production.
כלומר איך אנחנו נותנים רדיקליות שהן תלויות אחת בשנייה לרצף, בהינתן שההנחות של כל מערכות של H2 מתקיימות.
אבל סך הכל היו הנחות אי תלות חזקות מאוד, בייחוד כן.
האם כן האי תלות המותנה בין האי לאחרים בהינתן וואי איי.
וגם זה המודל הנרטיבי. אמרנו? אם החסרונות שיש, לא דיברנו על זה בשיעור הקודם,
אז בעצם השאלה אם אנחנו יכולים להמשיך איזשהו סקרים לטיב מודל שגם יגלם את התובנה הזאת של קוביות או משהו דומה לזה,
ומה שיאפשר לנו אולי למידה יעילה Influence יעיל?
כן, זה אפילו לאו דווקא חייב להיות ממש מרקוב כפי שאנחנו נראה בהמשך, אבל הנקודה היא שעדיין נוכל לעשות למידה יעילה.
עדיין נוכל לעשות Influence יעיל, אבל להנות מהכוח של מודלים, דיסקים, נתיבים כמו למשל לובלין מוטורס שדיברנו עליה פעם קודם.
אז המודל הראשון שנדבר עליו נקרא מקסימום אין סופי מרקוב.
אוקיי, מקסימום אנטרופי, מרקוב מודל או לפעמים קוראים להם m היא m.
אוקיי, הם הם הם בעצם מודלים לסקרים ונתיבים הם מודלים לא לינאריים או שמורכבים מאלמנטים.
מה כן? מה גורמים במכפלה שהם גורמים לא לא לינאריים שמשמש לשיקול סלייטר.
ומה הרעיון כאן? אז דבר ראשון כמודל להסכמי נתיבי מה שהוא מגדיר זה את התפלגות המוכנה.
אה נכון, תודה. כן, אז מה שיש לי זה בעצם עכשיו את ההסתברות המותנה של הוואי בהינתן איקסים.
ואני הולך בעצם לכתוב אותה כמו שתמיד אפשר לכתוב אותה על השרשרת כמכפלה של סוכנויות של הוואי.
איי. בהינתן לקודמים ותמיד אני משתנה על האיקסים כמובן, הם תמיד Observer במקרה של מודלים מתסכלים לטיניים.
ואני הולך עכשיו להניח הנחה דומה על הנחת ההנחה של Home.
אני הולך להניח שהוא WiFi. הם מהווים שרשרת מרקוב במקרה כאן שרשרת מרקוב מסדר ראשון.
אבל ההבדל מהיישומים שכאן זה בעצם הולכת להיות אי תלות מותנה.
כן, זה הולך להיות שהם מהווים שרשרת מרקוב בהינתן האיקס.
אוקיי, כי הכל בהינתן האיקס במודלים הבסיסיים, אז אני אלך להניח שאם מכפלה הזאת נראית כך בסדר,
לפחות עבור מודל פאי, גם המודל Trigger אם זה יהיה אחד y מינוס שתיים כן, זה אתם כבר מכירים.
וזה דבר אחד שאני הולך להניח. דבר שני שאני הולך להניח זה שכל אחד מהגורמים האלה.
וואי i בהינתן y מינוס אחד, כל אחד מהגורמים האלה הוא.
כל אחד מהגורמים האלה הוא מודל, לא גלינה. כלומר כל אחד מהגורמים האלה.
אפשר לכתוב אותו כ e בחזקה של איזשהו score function לינארי, כלומר מכפלה של weight וקטור כפול פיצ'ר ווקטור כן מנורמה ולכן מרמה.
ל 1 זה כמובן צריך להיות התפלגות אז זה.
על פני כל האפשרויות השונות לוואי AI אחד לאחד אז אני צריך לסכום על פני כל האפשרויות השונות לווי i ולחלק בגורם אני רוצה.
אוקיי, אז זה בעצם מודל שמורכב מן מכפלה של מודלים של מודל מלא בלי נערים ויש לו כן כמודל לא?
גלינארי. בעצם יש לו איזשהו פיצ'ר Function שאם אנחנו רגילים של function במודל log לינארי הוא מקבל את x ו y.
נכון אמרנו, דיברנו על הבלוק מתישהו. נכון שבעצם זה תלוי רק בX, אבל הY בוחר איזה בלוק אנחנו מסתכלים עליו.
אז כאן יש לנו משהו דומה? כן, אבל שימו לב שיש כאן איזשהו הבדל קטן, אבל חשוב שבעצם כל אחד מהנושאים האלה כן.
כל אחד מהמודלים הנערים האלה מתאים לא רק על איקס אחד איקסים, אלא גם על הוואי הקודם, ולכן הפיצ'ר Function.
הוא גם צריך להיות תלוי כמובן בו בצבע בולט וכן באינדקס איי.
למה לא כי אולי קצת שונים. הפיצ'ר Function.
זה אלמנט מוכפל, מוכפל, אבל גם בו Wii הקודם בסדר.
אז כאן אנחנו כבר רואים איזשהו יתרון שיש לנו.
תציע זאת. כן, מה שנקרא בלוק מתיישן, כי אחרת היינו צריכים להבחין בעצם להגיד הוואי.
האם מינוס אחד הוא אובזרבר עבור הפיצ'ר Function הY האהוב?
לא, וזה מסבך את המוטציה. כאן הכל נכנס לאותו קוד נכנס כי הארגומנט בתוך הפיצ'ר Function.
זה יותר פשוט. כן, אתה יכול שתסבירו למה אנחנו צריכים אולי.
עכשיו אנחנו כבר כאילו הוציאה מכונית. יש מעל הטלפון שלה, אז תכף אנחנו מיד נראה למה.
זה בעצם מאוד מתבקש להסתכל עליהם. כמובן, את לא חייב כבר להתעלם הארגומנט הזה.
נכון, כמו תמיד, פונקציה יכולה להיות קבועה באחד הרגימנטים שלה, אבל אנחנו נראה תכף שזה מאוד מתבקש שזה יהיה תלוי בסדר.
אז איך נראה הפיצ'ר הזה? סטיישן במקרה הזה קוראים לזה לפעמים גם history בפלייסטיישן.
כן, בעצם במקום לקרוא לזה אובזרבר.
אבל נכון. אם קודם לכן נגיד בקטלוג ליניארי מודל של השיעור הקודם בסטייג הסטנדרטי, אז דיברנו בעצם על זה שיש לנו פיצ'ר הפרסומות הישן של האובזרבר,
נכון, ועל לייבל זה מה שמקבל הפיצ'ר שלו, אבל עכשיו זה בעצם מקבל גם את האובזרבר בול, אבל גם את הפרי.
דיסקציה של השלב הקודם, או אם זה טריגר המודל שני הקודמים, אז קוראים לזה לפעמים ביחד.
History Station. כן, זה סתם פשוט אם תשנו את השם הזה, כי כאילו זה גם ההיסטוריה של הפרויקט.
אבל זה לא נורא משנה. אנחנו מניחים כרגיל שהיא פונקציה ממשית.
כן שמקבלת כן. את כל הארגומנט שהיא מקבלת ראינו קודם מחזירה מספר ממשי.
תכלס, לצרכים של NLP זה כמעט תמיד יהיו פונקציות אינדיקטור בדיוק מאותה סיבה שדיברנו עליה.
כן, בדיוק מאותה סיבה שדיברנו עליה. בהקשר של שרשור שעבר של מודלים של מודלים לוג לינאריים, אבל באופן כללי אפשר להרחיב את זה.
אנחנו כמובן מניחים שיש לה איזשהו מימד מסוים נתון.
אנחנו מכירים את הפיצ'ר Function. בשלב הזה היא לא נלמדת.
כן, זה פשוט איזשהו פיצ'ר מדי, אולי Created.
בשלב הזה של הקורס,
שבהינתן הרומנטים שלה מחזירה לנו איזשהו וקטור של אפסים ואחדים באופן כללי באופן רגיל במקרה של פארטו Speed שתגיב מה שיהיה לנו נגיד עכשיו עליתי לפריים.
המודל פשוט כחלק מהפיצ'רים יהיה יותר קל להסביר ככה.
אז בעצם יש לנו את כל ההיסטוריות?
כן, שהרבה פעמים פשוט מסמנים אותם כ איקס. כן, כלומר שני התגים הקודמים באמצע טריגר המודל או אחד הקודמים זה by, גרמו השלושה הקודמים, זה גרם, וכן הלאה.
את כל המשפט עצמו כן, כי עכשיו אנחנו לא צריכים רק להניח משהו על האיקס הספציפי.
הכל האיקס תמיד אובזרבר תמיד יכולים לקבל אותו המומנט ואינדקס הוואי זה כאילו כן כותבים את זה במוטציה הזאת.
זה בעצם הלייבל הנוכחי. כן יכול לקבל כל אחד מהפרטים האפשריים, ועכשיו אנחנו חופשיים להגדיר את הפיצ'רים כרצוננו.
באופן עקרוני יש איזשהם הנחות על הקשר בין הפיצ'רים.
יש אמרנו, זה פונקציה לינארית, אבל באופן מעשי אפשר לקחת כאן פיצ'רים מאוד הטרוגניים עם הרבה עובר ביניהם, וזה עדיין עובד בצורה די אפקטיבית.
אז שני הפיצ'רים בעצם או שני סוגי הפיצ'רים הראשונים שאנחנו בדרך כלל?
שאנחנו בדרך כלל מכניסים הם פיצ'רים שאני מניח שיהיו לכם מאוד מוכרים.
אחד מהם אפשר לקרוא להם mission features. כן.
מה הכוונה? אלה בעצם פיצ'רים שמה שהם מקודדים זה בדיוק את מה שקודמו על ידי Mission לטיס במקרה של HTML.
אז למשל, בוא נגיד פיצ'ר מספר אחד סתם לשם הדוגמה, הוא אחד ממנו, בדרך כלל בינאריים.
כן, אז הוא דולק. אם המילה הנוכחית האיקס i היא המילה base והמותג הנוכחי הוא VT.
מעבד chain זה לא משווה איזשהי קטגוריה. אז תשימו לב זה פיצ'ר שהוא מקבל את הערך אחת אך ורק אם שני הדברים מתקיימים, אחרת הוא מקבל אפס.
כנל אנחנו יכולים שיהיה לנו פיצ'ר אחר שהוא איקס איי אם שהוא נדלק.
אם איקס ריי הוא cat ומתי הוא פרי פוזישן וכן הלאה.
עכשיו תשימו לב שכל הפיצ'רים האלה ביחד. אם אתם לוקחים את כל נשרטט את.
כן, אז אנחנו עכשיו מסתכלים על הפיצ'ר ווקטור. נגיד שזה טריגר מודל.
אז וואי כן הוכרז T מינוס 1 בסדר עם מינוס אחד מינוס 2 או במוטציה שהשתמשנו בה קודם.
וואי האם מינוס אחת מהשתיים איי וכל האיקס?
סימנתי את זה. וקטור הכוונה כל המשפט עצמו. אז בעצם אנחנו אומרים וזה אמור להחזיר.
מה וקטור באורך בעצם? המון אוקיי, אז פה נוצר אותו גדול.
אז בעצם עכשיו אני חושב על הבלוק הראשון. של הווקטור הזה בתור משהו בגודל של אוצר המילים כפול מספר התגיות בסדר עבור כל קומבינציה של מילה ותג.
אז יהיה לי פה פיצ'ר אחד שהוא דוב ואני אקרא לו.
כן mission. כן, mission dog ו.
ואחרי זה יש לנו עם מי שזה כן סקסי ואז.
וכן הלאה וכן הלאה עבור כל קומבינציה. כי בעולם.
כן וזה אחד. כל אחד מאלה הוא אחד או אפס ופשוט אחד או אפס.
עכשיו השאלה שלכם היא כזאת. בהינתן INPUT מסוים לפיצ'ר function אוקיי, כלומר סדרה מסוימת של שני תגים אחרונים.
כן, סליחה, אני צריך פה עוד את התג הנוכחי. של תג הנוכחי שני תגים אחרונים, האינדקס והמשפט בהינתן הסכמה מסוימת לעימותים שלהם.
כמה פיצ'רים מתוך הבלוק הזה הם אחד וכמה הם האפס?
אחד רק אחד נכון.
כי אם אני יודע שהמילה כן, שהמילה היא i נגיד שווה חמש כן, אז אני עכשיו שואל האם הY i הנוכחי שלי הוא ורבע האיקס כן, האיקס שלי הוא דוג, אז זה אחד או אפס?
כן. ואם זה אחד אז בטוח שעבור כל שאר הקומבינציות הם כולם אפס ותמיד יש אחד כזה.
בהנחה שהוא פספסתי שום דבר. אז אוקי, אז יש לנו פה מלא מלא פיצ'רים, וקטור נורא נורא ארוך שכתוב בו אחד וכל השאר הם אפסים.
בסדר. כן אפילו.
גודל אוצר מילים כפול, מספר תגיות. אוקיי.
ותזכרו שהדבר הזה אחרי זה אנחנו הולכים ללמוד כמובן. וויץ לכל אחד מהם בסדר.
זאת אומרת הדבר הזה אחרי זה יעבור. נכון? איך זה בעצם?
איך אנחנו הולכים להשתמש בזה? אחרי זה הדבר הזה יעבור מכפלה סקלרית.
עם איזשהו וקטור של Whats. נכון?
שבו יהיה כתוב. נגיד למשל אם יהיה כתוב שם מינוס שמונה מאות.
נגיד, אז זה אומר שדב ובר היא כנראה קומבינציה ממש גרועה.
כן, לפחות לפי הפרמטרים האלה של המודל.
אבל אם כתוב שם פלוס לא יודע מה אלף שמונה מאות זה אומר שבעצם הם הולכים ממש טוב יחד.
משהו כזה? בסדר.
אז יש את זה לכל אחד. אוקיי.
כן, ובדיוק וזאת באמת השאלה למה אנחנו צריכים גם להכניס פה את האינדקס?
כן? כי אם לא היינו מכניסים פה את האינדקס, בעצם אפילו לא היינו יודעים באיזה איקס לבחור, לאיזה איקס אנחנו עכשיו מסתכלים.
נכון, כי כל פעם הוא מקבל. רק כן אם זה Try גם שלושה לייבלים, אם זה פוגש ארבעה, אם זה בייגל שניים וכן הלאה.
אבל הוא מקבל את כל האיקס.
כן, זה תמיד אפשר לקחת בחשבון את האיקס, אז זה מאוד טבעי ולפעמים גם אנחנו רוצים אולי להכניס בייס, נגיד לתחילת המשפט בייס לסוף המשפט.
כן, גם כל מיני דברים כאלה. יפה.
אז זה דבר ראשון. ווינטג עבור כל ווינטג פר חוץ מזהה.
אנחנו גם נרצה להכניס כן, תכף אני אחזור לאלה, אבל חוץ מזה אנחנו גם נרצה להכניס פיצ'רים שבעצם הם מקבילים לפנטזיה של פר ופילאטיס.
אוקיי, אז למשל, היינו רוצים שיהיה פה פיצ'ר שהוא דולק אם הוא דולק.
כן, אפשר לכתוב את זה. זה קיטור. כן, זה.
בוא נכתוב את זה יותר יפה. זה האינדיקטור function של X i שווה טוב.
וואי וואי כן ויש לנו המון כאלה עד פה וזה האינדיקטור של why i שווה v סליחה i מינוס אחד ואם y מינוס שתיים שווה start?
אוקיי, אז עכשיו יש לנו גם כזה ואנחנו גם כאלה צריכים כנראה לכל שלישיה, אלא אם יש שישיות שמראש אנחנו חושבים שאין טעם לקודד אותם.
כנראה שלא. וזה בדיוק מקביל ל transit part באילת.
כן, אם פה יהיה ערך גבוה שמתאים לזה איזשהו ביט חיובי גבוה מה זה אומר?
שזה כן שזה שילוב שהגיוני נכון ורק אחרי נאום וג'יי זה משהו אחרי ניווט זה משהו ממש סבבה, אבל אם זה ממש נמוך אז כנראה שזה אומר לא.
אם הגעת למצב הזה תפסול את זה מיד. זה כנראה גרוע.
אז גם כאן יש לנו בלוק בגודל. כמה סליחה, מתעלם.
כן האצבע שלישית נכון של טייגר.
אבל בעצם. למה להסתפק בת רגע? אמרנו שלפעמים אנחנו הרי עושים בכסף.
נכון, עושים אומרים לא אתרי גרא מוס פרסי מדי.
כמעט לא נתקלתי בזה. כנראה שלי שם לא מאוד אמין.
אז בוא נעשה back of כאן יותר פשוט פשוט נכניס גם פיצ'רים של ביקראם לתוך הסיפור.
כן. אז נגיד, יכול להיות שגם יהיה לנו פיצ'רים כמו פיצ'ר 104 שכתוב כאן שומר הוואי הקודם אמרו כן.
Edge אקטיב has Edge Active והוואי הנוכחי הוא טרנזיטיבי.
אוקיי, אז יהיה לנו פה עוד נגיד וואי I do i מינוס 1.
סליחה או ויקם? וכן הלאה.
וכן יהיה עוד S בריבוע פיצ'רים כאלה ואולי גם יוני גם כן אנחנו.
מה זה אומר? יוני גרם? מה ההיגיון של יוני גרם? בואו נחשוב על זה שנייה.
של יוני גם, אבל רק תזכור זה יוני גם שהוא רק אומר האם הWIFI הוא הוא נעם או WiFi הוא רפה זיכרון.
מה אתה אומר בדיוק? זה בעצם אומר תראו, יכול להיות שיש לי קטגוריות שכמעט לא מופיעות לפי הסטרימינג.
די החלטתי. זה קטגוריה שוואלה, אם יש לך אופציה טובה אחרת עדיף להימנע.
כן, נורא נדירה, לא מתאים, אז אנחנו נרצה שמה יהיה wait.
כנראה שנצמד לה ללא האינדיקטור שלה או להפך.
נמוך אפילו מתחת לאפס. אולי. למה לא?
כאילו זה יכול להיות כל מספר ממשי. בסדר, אז אנחנו יכולים לשלב ביניהם ואיכשהו לראות מה כן לתת.
או לקוות שהמודל ילמד Wait מתאימים.
אפשר גם לקחת כל מיני דברים. כן, רק שנייה אחת, כל מיני דברים הטרוגניים כאלה.
כן, כמו מין זה מין Mission עקום.
אתם יכולים לחשוב על זה נכון? זה אומר המילה הנוכחית היא זה טיפה, והמילה לפניהם היא זה.
אוקיי, אז זה כמו עם Mission, אבל למי שיש כזה שמסתכל אחורה אוקיי,
או המילה הבאה היא וזה טרנזיטיבי או כל מיני דברים, אתם יודעים, אתם יכולים להיכנס וגם למה לעצור שם?
אתם יכולים גם להכניס כל מיני פיצ'רים אותו גרפים שדיברנו עליהם או מורפולוגי,
כמו למשל האם המילה מסתיימת ב ING ועיוור או האם מילה מסוימת באנג'י וינר מין מסויים באנג'י ויש ג'קטים וכן הלאה.
או האם המילה מתחילה בענן או בפרי או וואטאבר במה שאתם רוצים או מה האורך של
המילה או כל מיני דברים שונים ומשונים שקשורים פשוט לצורה שבה המילה כתובה נכון,
בייחוד שפות שיש להם מורפולוגיה יחסית עשירה. נגיד, תחשבו על עברית לדוגמה, אז הרבה פעמים המילים האלה יכולות להיות אינדיקציה די חזקה, נכון?
מילה נגיד שמתחילה ב שנגיד מסתיימת באות כי לא נכון תו זה.
אם יש ניקוד נגיד שיש ניקוד אז כנראה זה נראה הרבה פעמים נכון.
אבל אם זה אות אז אולי זה רבות כאילו נקבה רבים וכן הלאה.
תלוי בשפה, אבל כל פנים יכולים לקודד כל מיני פיצ'רים כאן ויש לנו מרחב פעולה די גדול.
כן, נכון שהגדרנו לא נכון לכולם לא?
אז באיזה שהוא אופן, אבל בעצם? אז בוא נחשוב על זה שניה.
בעצם יש לך איזשהו פיצ'ר שהוא פיצ'ר שבעצם או אפשר לחשוב עליו.
כי בעצם כמו שאתה אומר DC פונקציה נכון, מין או או זה או זה או זה או זה או זה או זה או זה.
אז שם מבחינה לוגית כמובן שאתה צודק.
כן אפשר להסיק אותו אחד מהשני, אבל בגלל שהמודל הזה מוגבל ב אקספרסיביות שלו נכון?
כי זה סך הכל מכפלה לינארית של דברים, אז אתה מקבל ערך, מקודד אותו בנפרד.
אתה צודק שאם היה לי מודל יותר אקספרסיבי נגיד זה היו פיצ'רים שנכנסים לתוך איזה רשת קטנה ומוטה,
אז הסיפור אחר, וכנראה היינו צריכים הרבה פחות יתירות בדרך הזאת.
איזשהו? עוד שאלות.
כן, נכון. אה אוקיי.
כן, בטח. אז כל אחד מהאגפים. כאילו איך את יודעת sub סקריפט אז שהוא מספר זה בעצם אחת מהקורבנות כאן.
אז כן, אז הווקטור הזה הוא בדרך כלל וקטור של מיליונים בקלות, לפעמים אפילו הרבה יותר.
הוא מאוד. אבל מצד שני זה גם צריך לומר נכון, כאילו תכל'ס את יכולה, כנראה כדאי לך לייצג אותו.
מי שמכיר כאן כאילו הנביאים של Spark וקטור spark מטריקס, אז אני לא יודע אם אתם למדתם על זה.
לא משנה העובדה שהוא Spark גם מאוד מקלה מבחינה חישובית, אבל זה אני כאילו אומר רק בסוגריים.
אבל על כל פנים זה וקטור מאוד מאוד מאוד ארוך שיש לו רק מספר די קטן של קואורדינטות שם אחד עבור כל input נתון וכו.
ואלה פשוט דוגמאות לדברים שעשויים להיות כאן ובדרך כלל חושבים עליו כי בלוקי מטבע הדברים כי את לא מכניסה בדרך כלל feature node שאומר כן.
אם זה מתחיל בB ונגמר בA ויש את זה, את לא עושה דברים כאלה.
את בדרך כלל אומרת טוב, אז עכשיו אני אקח לכל האותיות האפשריות שמתחילות מילה ולכל האותיות האפשריות שמסיימות מילה.
אני אקח את כל הקומבינציות שלהן ואכניס קפיצה. ואז בעצם זה יצא לך בלוק של פיצ'רים שעבור כל INPUT ספציפי מקבל אחד כנראה באחד הקואורדינטות.
כל השאר אפסים. טוב. זה די הגדרה של בלוק.
כאילו את יודעת. את חופשייה להגדיר את זה כרצונך. כרגע זה מניו הליקופטר Features.
אני אומרת בדרך כלל הפיצ'רים האלה נוצרים על ידי Patterns כאלה.
כן, בעצם הם נוצרים. את יודעת בסיטונאות כאילו את לא מתחילה לחשוב אה, כדאי לי להכניס הצג.
את אומרת יאללה, נכניס פה את כל הקומבינציות של אותיות, התחלה וסוף.
נגיד עכשיו אני אכניס את הכול המודל ואתן לו ללמוד את הדאבל U שבאמת כי יכול להיות שחלק מהן באמת לא אומרות כלום על הפרט הספיציפי,
בסדר, אז הם יקבלו אפס מהם, ואפילו שיש שם אינדיקטור בסוף יוכפל באפס או במשהו נורא קטן והוא לא ישפיע בשום צורה.
כן, אבל את אומרת בוא ניתן אם יש לך מספיק דאטה, אתה הרבה פעמים אומר בוא ניתן למודל כאילו להבין את זה.
כמובן שאם את יודעת יותר איזה פיצ'רים אמורים להיות טובים ואיזה פחות, אז אז אולי תשתמשי בזה כדי לנפות חלק מהם, לא?
עוד שאלות. אוקיי. יפה.
אז מה שאנחנו עושים זה בעצם מקבלים מין סדרה ארוכה ארוכה כזאת של כן של אפסים ואחדים זה יוכפל.
Wait וקטור וזה ייתן לנו את.
בעצם זה ייתן לנו את ה score מה שמופיע כאן ב האקספוננט נעלה אותו ב האקספוננט.
נבדוק את זה על פני כל האפשרויות השונות לווי i וככה נקבל התפלגות יפה.
אז איך אנחנו לומדים את הסיפור הזה? איך אנחנו בעצם לומדים את ה weight וקטור במודל m?
אז כרגיל אנחנו רוצים להשתמש במקלדת. מקסימום לייק. להיות station הולך את זה לסרגל הריצה וכאלה זה כבר סטנדרט.
אז איך נראה? איך נראה בעצם? איך נראה הלייק?
לראות איך נראית הלייק Function במקרה הזה אנחנו מדברים על סופר היי setting.
נכון יש לנו אין גדול דוגמאות אימון, כלומר סדרות של Y ושל איקסים.
שאנשים תשימו לב שעכשיו אנחנו כן יהיה לנו.
מציע קצת לא יודע, מסורבלת אבל בלתי נמנעת.
בגלל שבעצם יש לנו הרבה סדרות וכל אחת מהסדרות האלה יש אינדקס בתוך הסדרה.
נכון? אז בעצם כדי להבחין בין הדברים, האינדקס של הטרנינג Example הוא יהיה בסופר script בסוגריים.
זה האינדקס של מילה בתוך הסדרה.
הוא יהיה בסנסקריט בסדר. אז וואי ג'יי סופר script.
איי אומר הלייבל הנכון של המילה הג'איינטס בפריים מוגזם.
I בסדר. יפה, אז אנחנו רוצים להסתכל על הקומדי שמוליק להוריד.
כלומר ההסתברות של וואי אחד ה y n גדול.
בהינתן איקס חרדי קטן גדול, הדבר הזה שווה למכפלה על פני כל טריינינג example i שווה אחד יותר גדול מכפלה על פני כל המעברים הלא קלים.
כלומר ג'י שווה אחד עד אין איי.
איי זה האורך של טריינינג. סמפל האי של ההסתברות של wi fi בהינתן with a מינוס אחד i ואיקס i זה יבוא המקרה של By גרם מודל
אם זה try גרם model אז צריך לענות על שני החיים הקודמים קצת פור גרם אז השלושה הקודמים וכן הלאה.
בסדר, ועכשיו אנחנו מניחים שכל אחד מהגורמים האלה הוא לא גלינארי, כזכור.
כלומר, יש פה איזשהו פיצ'ר Function שמקבל את האינדקס שני ה y עם הקודמים ואת כל המילים במשפט עושה לזה מכפלה סקלרית עם הוויט וקטור דאבליו,
שאותו אנחנו בעצם תכף נרצה למצוא. לצערך וחלקי זה שהוא בעצם Partition Function הוא גורם נירמול והוא שווה לסכום על פני כל האפשרויות השונות.
עבור וואי ג'יי, כן, האקספוננט של F ג'יי אחד, I x i.
בסדר שאלות זה פשוט כתבתי את המודעה מחדש כחלק מלאי כבוד.
כן, יש כבר של.
במאי 2010 אחד. הוא מדבר על כך שזה נכון בדיוק.
בסדר, ועכשיו כרגיל אנחנו אוהבים לעבוד, אבל אנחנו אוהבים לעבוד.
בלוגים, בלוג Like לקרוא עוד. אז אנחנו לוקחים לוג הסכום הופך למכפלה המונה שהוא בעצם האקספוננט של משהו.
האקספוננט מתבטל ואנחנו מקבלים פה את ה score.
כן של כל אחד מהמעברים פחות לוג של Partition function של גורם נרמול ולזה אפשר.
אפשר לגזור את זה או כן לקחת את הגרדיאנט. וגם כאן כמו דנילו גלינארי, זה כנראה לא יפתיע אתכם שכשאתם עושים את הם כן כשאתם עושים את.
אתה דר מבצע את הגזירה. אז מה שאתם מקבלים זה משהו מאוד דומה למה שראינו בשבוע שעבר אם לא גלי ניר Models.
כלומר אתם מקבלים שהקודם נטה הקייט, כלומר הנגזרת הקייט נגזרת חלקית הקייט של הלא בלייק ליהוד זה בסדר סכום על פני כל הדוגמאות,
סכום על פני כל המעברים של הפיצ'ר הזה עבור Y הנכונים.
כן, עבור ה soul solution עבור הווי ג'י איי ג'יי מינוס אחד i פחות.
התוחלת של הפיצ'ר הזה כשווי עובר כן שווים.
ג'יי בעצם עובר על פני כל הערכים האפשריים. עבור כן, זה לגמרי אנלוגי למקרה שדיברנו עליו שדיברנו עליו בשיעור שעבר.
עבור לא בלי נייר מודל פשוט. אז אני לא אחזור על הדרישות.
אתם רוצים להשתכנע? מוזמנים לעשות את זה בעצמכם. T זה סט הלייבלים?
בסדר. ועכשיו בעצם מה שאנחנו רואים מהנוסחה הזאת זה שזה אומנם נוסחה קצת מסובכת, אבל תכלס אין כאן משהו שהוא יצא קצת בול.
בוא נחשוב שנייה, יש לכם איזשהו טריינינג אם זה אמפר נכון או מורכב מאין גדול?
שרשראות באורך באורכים שונים. אין לי אורך כל שרשרת.
אתם עכשיו יש לכם איזשהו ניחוש? התחלתי לדבליו. נכון?
אתם עושים איזשהו סוג של גרדיאנט, של גובה, עדיין תשנט.
אתם יכולים לחשב את הפיצ'ר function עבור כל solution שנתון לכם.
אתם יכולים גם אחרי זה לעבור על פני כל הלייבלים האפשריים.
נגיד שזה כמה עשרות, אם זה פר תצפית שטקסט לכל אחד מהם לחשב את הפיצ'ר ווקטור.
לקחת ממוצע משוקלל שלהם לפי ההסתברויות שאתם מקבלים עבור ה דאבליו הנוכחי ולחשב את זה זה אולי יהיה טיפה כאב ראש, אבל סך הכל משהו.
אין כאן איזושהי בעיה של חישוב אקספוננציאלי או של שום דבר כזה.
כן, כל הסכומים כאן הם כן, זה בעצם זה סכום על אין גדול.
זה סכום על האורכים, זה סכום על.
זה סכום על מספר התגיות. וההסתברות הזאת עצמה גם היא כוללת את ה partition function.
נכון, גם היא כוללת את הפרטי של פעם בשנה וגם הוא בסך הכל סכום על מספר התגיות.
אז סך הכל יש לנו. לא יודע משהו כמו אן.
כן, כמספר המעברים הכולל בכל הדוגמאות כפול משהו שהוא סדר גודל של מספר התגיות בריבוע.
לא נשמע כל כך נורא טוב.
זה אפשרי כי זה פילים וזה מתכנס והם מגיעים לאיזשהו טבלאות.
שמנו קסם. טלי מה לגבי Influence?
כן. מה לגבי עסק? אז במקרה של עסק אנחנו זוכרים את האלגוריתם ויתר.
במקרה של HTML למדנו אותו לא מזמן. מסתבר שהוא עובד כאן בשינויים מאוד קלים.
בדיוק באותו אופן, מה הסיבה שהוא עובד באותו אופן?
כי גם כאן בעצם אנחנו יכולים לכתוב את ההסתברות של שרשרת של Y כמכפלה על פני מעברים לוקאלי,
בעצם על פני פקטורים שכל אחד מהם תלוי רק באם זה By גרם מודל מעבר בין נוסחת לוואי.
אם זה Try גרם למעבר בין y מינוס שתיים y מינוס אחד ל why i, אז בעצם גם כאן אפשר בצורה אנלוגית לגמרי להגדיר את ה בעצם את ההסתברות של הרישא.
כן או את המשקל החלקי, את המשקל של איזשהו רישא של הפתרון T1 הטיקי כמכפלה על המעברים TI.
בהינתן תהייה מנוסחת, תהיה מינוס שתיים. אם זה טייגר המודל X אחד עד אין i כמכפלה עד קיי.
להגדיר שוב dynamic programming table.
כן, ששומר ב קיי חיובי את ההסתברות המקסימלית של מסלול שמסתיימת בחיובי ומכסה את התגיות הראשונות ונרצה למצוא את הפאי.
כלומר נרצה למצוא את את אותו אופטיים. אם נרצה לחשב את פאי פשוט כ מקסימום על פני כל האתרים השונים של התיוג של k מינוס שתיים,
התגיות הראשונות בשתי האחרונות נקבעות פשוט על ידי הארגומנט, וגם את זה אפשר לפתור עם נוסחאות רקורסיבית אנלוגית לגמרי.
מתחילים מסלול באורך אפס. Start Start זה אחד, והנוסחה רקורסיבית, אומרת לנו פיקי.
חיובי זה מקסימום על פני כל הערכים האפשריים ל בעצם על פני כל המצבים שמהם אני יכול להגיע.
ליובי. מה הם המצבים שמהם אני יכול להגיע ליובי בדיוק כמו קודם?
זה כל המצבים PU כשהגיעו הוא אותו יום מכאן.
ושטי הוא אחת מהאפשרויות. לכן, מינוס שתיים בעצם נכון לתג שלפני הקודם.
ועכשיו אני מסתכל על אופטימוס שמגיע אליו כפול הצלע.
המשקל של הצלע שמעבירה אותי ליובי, שזה בדיוק קיצור של וי בהינתן טיפ סי קיו וכל משפט וקיי שהם פשוט גבוהים.
וככה בעצם לחשב את הצד הרקורסיה כאילו את השכבה הבאה בהינתן השכבה הקודמת אז יש שאלות לגבי זה?
או שמישהו כאן כאילו היה רוצה שאני אחשוב קצת יותר בפרוטרוט למה זה נקרא אנלוגי לגמרי?
לא היית שמן או שזה סך הכל היה ברור מההסבר הזה?
יש שם דרישה מהקהל, לא? אוקיי.
טוב, בסדר, כן.
אז שוב אותו טריילר גרף. כמעט זהה למקרה של Home.
חוץ מה ההבדל בעצם? נגיד זה נקרא בית?
כן? מה ההבדל היחיד? בעצם המשקלים על הצלעות?
נכון, אם במקרה של Home מה היו המשקלים על הצלעות?
מה בסך? בעצם m זה היה ה x האחרון נכון?
וגם מכפלה עם הטרנזיט הישן נכון, כי זה היה שני גורמים שונים.
אתה מזה ישן ואני Mission. כאן אין Mission האיקסים בטנים עליהם.
נכון זה מודל הסכם נתיבי. כל מה שיש זה Transmission בהינתן האיקס, בהינתן המשפט נכון, כי אם ניזכר בנוסחה של אמ.
אז בעצם אם ימ הוא מכפלה נכון, ההסתברות של שרשרת שלמה היא מכפלה על הסתברויות המעברים.
אין כאן שני גורמים שאני צריך להכפיל בהם, כמו בייט שבהם זה לא מכפלה על Visions כפול מכפלה.
למשל. אין לי פה את משבצת האיקסים. הם תמיד, אבל זה תמיד בצד המותנה.
זה מודל תסכל נתיבי. כל מה שיש לי זה מכפלה על כביש.
אז בהינתן האיקסים, כפועל יוצא גם במשקלי הצלעות הם פשוט הפקטורים האלה כן מחושבים ככה מודל לא?
גלינארי. אין לי פה שני גורמים להכפיל. זה ההבדל היחיד.
חוץ מזה זה בדיוק אותו מקרה. בסדר, אז אז זה בעצם כן, זה פותר את אביתר הרבה.
וכן, זה בעצם זהה לחלוטין.
Hold עכשיו יש לי רק עוד כמה דקות אז אני אתחיל את החלק הבא אני, אבל כן רוצה לדבר עליו בקצרה, לתת קצת מוטיבציה.
אז בעצם מה שאנחנו נדבר עליו באח? זאת אומרת, המודל הבא שהוא גם יהיה מודל דיסקים מנתיבי אצבעות בו אתה בשקפים הבאים.
הוא מנסה להתמודד עם זה בעצם עם איזושהי בעיה.
איזשהו בייס שיש לה מודלים, מי הם, הם והצורה שהוא הולך להתמודד עם זה זה בעצם לשים לב שהנחת אמר קוביות שאנחנו מניחים בהם.
אמ. כן, הנחת אמר קוביות. כלומר שבועיים הם מהווים שרשרת מרקוב.
בהינתן האיקסים זה עובר כאילו ביחס למה שאנחנו צריכים.
אנחנו חיים להסתפק בהנחה קצת יותר חלשה מזאת כן, שכוללת את זה כמקרה פרטי,
אבל היא יותר מאפשרת כי בעצם הרעיון הרעיון הוא כזה אומר הדבר העיקרי בוא נחשוב על ביתר בשנייה.
כן, בשביל ביתר בי. מה בעצם אנחנו צריכים?
מה אנחנו צריכים מהנוסחה הזאת? איך היא צריכה להיראות? הדבר היחידי שאנחנו צריכים לדעת כדי שנוכל להשתמש בביתר.
בי זה שאזכור של סדרת לייבלים מתפרק כשקוראים על שרשראות קצרות, נגיד זוגות או שלשות או משהו כזה.
נכון, ברגע שיש לנו את זה אז אנחנו כותבים נגיד אם זה זוגות אז אנחנו מציירים את הטראנס גרף נכון, אנחנו מציירים את הטראנס, גרף אנחנו בונים את כן זה.
כן אנחנו מסתכלים על הטריילר. גרף אנחנו בונים כל אחד.
אנחנו כן מגדירים את המשקל של כל צלע בהתאם ל פקטורים האלה.
כן, שתלויים רק בקשר לוקאלי, כלומר באיזה מהלך עשיתי עכשיו?
אם זה קשר בן זוג אז בצורה הזאת. אם זה קשר בין שלישיה אז אני פשוט הופך כל קודקוד כאן לזוג נכון?
ואז מגדיר את זה עדיין כקשר בין שני קודקודים. אבל מה אני לא צריך להניח?
מה הדבר הנוסף? מה הכאילו הנחה מיותרת קצת שיש בהם ימים זאת ההנחה שהם פקטורים האלה.
הם בעצם מהווים התפלגות כן, כלומר, או אם אתם רוצים לחשוב על זה בצורה גרפית,
זה בעצם ההנחה שסכום כל המשקלים שיוצאים מהקודקוד מסוים, סכום כל הצלעות היוצאות, סכום משקלים שכל הצלעות היוצאות מהודקות דמה אחד.
נכון, במקרה הזה זה חייב להיות אחד. למה? איך חישבנו את זה בא ניזכר.
כל אחד מהם הוא האקספוננט של איזשהו סכום, ואז בסוף חילקנו בגורם שהוא פשוט סכום על פני כל הצלעות שיוצאות ממנו, נכון?
אז ברור שזה אחד. ככה בנינו את זה. כן, בנינו את זה בצורה שמה שנקראת לא כלי נורמלי כן?
כלומר כל אחד קודקודים הקשתות היוצאות מתנער מלוק לאחד.
אוקיי, אבל מה שעשיר אף יגיד זה למה אתה צריך את זה בכלל.
ויתר ויהיה עובד בדיוק באותה צורה. גם אם הצלעות האלה לא היו מסתכמות לאחד פעם הם היו מסתכמות ל 17, פעם היו מסתכמות ל 10 בחזקת מינוס חמש.
לא יודע מה, כל עוד הן מסתכמות לאיזה מספרים חיוביים.
כן שמסתכמים למשהו. לא אכפת לי אפילו מה זה.
אביתר העובד באותה צורה, מחלק את זה לתתי בעיות, מחפש את דימום, לתת בעיות.
מעריך את התת בעיות האלה. אין שום הבדל. כן? מה לא השתמשתי בשום נקודה בזה שהסכום שלהם הוא אחד.
עכשיו הנחת המרכזיות מחייבת אותי שהסכום יהיה אחד, כי אני מניח שפי של why i בהינתן i את צריכה שפי של כל הווים.
בהינתן האיקסים זה מכפלה על. על כן על מעברים שכל אחד מהם הוא הסתברות.
אבל אם נניח שזה לא מרקו בהכרח, אז זה כבר לאו דווקא מתקיים,
ועכשיו נחליף את ההנחה ל פשוט להניח שהמפלגות המשותפת של ווי אחד עד Y הן בהינתן איקס אחד הדי אן היא איזה שהיא.
מכפלה של גורמים חיוביים, היא איזושהי מכפלה של גורמים חיוביים שבסוף מסתכמת לאחד.
אז איך אפשר לעשות את זה? אפשר להגדיר וזה יהיה cross.
נתחיל לדבר על זה לעומק. בשיעור הבא אנחנו הולכים להניח שסדרה של ההסתברות של סדרה של Y בהינתן סדרה של איקסים, היא שווה ל.
בעצם, אנחנו שוב הולכים להניח שיש לנו פיצ'ר Function די דומה, או אולי אפילו זהה לזה הקודם M שכל פעם מקבל זוג או שלישיה,
אם זה טרייד דראם ואינדקס ואת כל האיקסים, ואחרי זה מוכפל בי דאבליו.
אבל אנחנו לא הולכים להניח שהדבר הזה מתפרק למכפלה שהיא כל פעם לא כלי נורמלי.
זאת אומרת שיש לי גורם נרמול כל פעם שדואג שכל מעבר יסתכם לאחד.
הדבר היחידי שאנחנו הולכים להניח זה שסכום כל ההסתברויות על פני כל המסלולים האפשריים מסתכמת ל 1 שנייה אחת.
איך עושים את זה? מחשבים את זה איזה שהוא גורם נרמול שסוכם על פני כל הקומבינציות האפשריות ל Y.
כלומר, יש פה סכימה אקספוננציאלי על פני כל הסדרות האפשריות באורך n של פרטי speech על המשקלים שלהם.
אוקיי, ואז אם הצלחנו לעשות את זה אז בטוח שהדבר הזה מסתכם לאחד.
כן, זאת אומרת שכל הדבר הזה מסתכם לאחד, כי זה פשוט סכימה על פני כל האפשרויות עבור המונה.
ועדיין נכון שאנחנו רוצים לעשות Insurance אז זה לא מעניין אותנו, נכון?
למה זה לא מעניין באינטרנט? כמה לא יודעים לקבוע כי כן בדיוק יום קבוע.
נכון, זה פשוט איזה שהוא קבוע, לא משנה מה הוא. אולי קשה לחשב אותו כי זה סכום של מלא דברים.
אבל עזבו אתכם, זה לא מעניין אותנו סך הכל קבוע.
מה שאנחנו צריכים זה את המונה. המונה מתפרק כפי שאתם רואים כמכפלה של גורמים לא קלים, אנו יכולים לעשות ביתר בי והגדלנו את אקספרסיביות של המודל.
למה לנו לעשות את זה? הגדלנו את אקספרסיביות כי כבר זה לא מסתכם לאחד בכל שנה.
למה לנו לעשות את זה? זאת אומרת איזה וי לייף מוטיב שני?
אז נדבר על זה בשיעור הבא. האם זה מקשה על הלמידה של הפרמטרים?
כן, אבל לא ברמה שאנחנו לא יכולים לפתור אותה, אבל זה נלמד בשיעור הבא.
כן, זה לא אנחנו. בואו נמשיך ככה זה מתחיל להראות.
בוא נאמר ככה אה? Framework כזה. מאפשר להכניס רשתות נוירונים בצורה די פשוטה, נגיד מנהלי בתי הספר.
סוג של לא שאני כן, אבל מה שיהיה נחמד פה זה שאנחנו נוכל לעשות אקזקט, אקזקט learning.
אוקיי, זה בעצם יהיה ההבדל. אקזקט Influence הכוונה היא שאתה יכול למצוא את השרשרת ממקסם את Y.
זה פשוט מטרדי מה שברשתות נוירונים שנלמד על אל על נורות לספקי סיכון ספציפי שאנחנו נראה שאנחנו לא יכולים למצוא את האופטימים בצורה מדוייקת.
אנחנו צריכים לקרב אותו ואנחנו נוכל למצוא. אנחנו נוכל לבצע למידה אופטימלית במובן הזה שנוכל למצוא את המקסימום הגלובלי של דאבליו בהינתן גיימינג Data,
וגם את זה לא נוכל לעשות ברגע שנעבור לדברים לא לינארית.
זה הפתיח בגידול הזה שהמשטח. איזה חמור אתה בדיוק?
אני מבטיח שיש מקסימום 6 שהמקסימום מה לוקאלי הוא גם מקסימום גלובלי.
אוקיי כן, באופן כללי יש לנו. אם זה היה לחפש את המילה הבאה זה בגלל זה.
אה כן כן, כן, אנחנו צריכים שכנראה מספר קטגוריות לא יהיה משהו לגמרי מפלצתי.
למה זה נראה? כי כולם על משהו אחר.
תראה, דבר ראשון זה מודל, לא? אני לא יודע אם זה נקרא לגרות.
זה אולי מהבחינה כאילו הסיבה שהוא מודל גרוע לתינוקות זה כי הוא מדד בסקרים לנתיב.
אבל הסיבה שהוא אם אתה צריך, אנחנו נראה בשיעור הבא.
שבעצם אם מספר קטגוריות האפשריות שמספר קטגוריות האפשריות הוא לא יכול, הוא כן מהווה.
הוא כן יעלה באיזושהי חזקה. כן? אז כן, אנחנו אולי לא ברמות שאנחנו מתעסקים בהם.
כן, לא ברמה של עשרות או מאות זה עדיין בסדר.
אולי אם היינו מדברים על מאות אלפים, כאילו כמו במילים, אז זה כן היה כבר משהו שהיה עשוי להציק, אבל זה כל זה.
אנחנו נראה בשיעור אפס. בשיעור הבא נבין אלף מה המוטיבציה האמיתית למודל הזה.
מעבר למוטיבציה התיאורטית של לא צריך שזה יסתכם לאחד.
בוא נעשה שזה מסתכם למשהו ואנחנו נראה איך עובדת הלמידה במקרה הזה וכמה היא מסובכת אז החליטו.
זה. ירידה.
אני לא יודע. יש אנשים שאוהבים.
בהקשר הרשמי של הסדרה ביותר, מקסימיליאן קוך מגיעה לישראל בצורה מיוחדת.
נכון, אני יכול לדבר על זה באופן כללי, לא בלי עמוד איזוטרי, מקסימום אינסוף לימוד.
אז. אני יודע שלא כולם, אבל תורת האינפורמציה.
טובה. סתם, פשוט היה לי תיאבון בדיוק לשבוע.
על איזה שליש ממנו היה על תורת האינפורמציה.
סליחה ואיזה קורס בלמידה עמוקה? אז זה של השפעת אלכוהול היה על זה?
ואמרתי לעצמי טוב, לפחות עכשיו אני יודע את ההגדרה היבשה.
תשלח לי מייל ואשלח לך את הרפרנס שמראה מה עושים.
בגדול, מה שאפשר להראות זה שהמודלים אנלוג לינארי הם מודלים שמפרסמים בצרות עין תחת ההנחה,
תחת אילוצים בעצם על עם אילוצים על כל מיני הסתעפויות שאתה כאילו מקבל.
שכן אז פלסטינים שלגביהם פורסם נמצא כל כך הרבה.
מידע משתמשים בדרך כלל בין 12 אלף שיש לכל רשת.
אז נגיד למשל אתה רוצה. אני כרגע בסבב הופעות.